madame monsieur bonsoir ici frédéric
arnould en direct de montréal bienvenue
à cette présentation spéciale sur
facebook live dans un peu moins de dix
minutes maintenant vous allez assister à
une émission spéciale présentée par
céline galipeau et qui s'appelle 11h59
pour la planète alors c'est une émission
qui va vous faire voyager un peu partout
dans le monde avec des reportages qui
ont été tournées par nos correspondants
et qui vont vous présenter des solutions
pour l'environnement c'est à dire que ce
soir c'est pas une émission on va se
lamenter sur évidemment les lits
catastrophe qui se succèdent et
changement climatique mais bien on va
vous donner quelques exemples de
solutions alors c'est une émission qui
va être présenté donc à 20 heures ici
radio canada télé mais également ici sur
facebook life on a décidé ce soir de
vous présenter cette émission pas comme
les autres dans un édifice qui s'appelle
la biosphère la biosphère c'est cette
espèce de grosse sphère métallique que
l'on voit lorsqu'on passe sur le pont
jacques-cartier et qui se trouve dans le
parc jean drapeau en face de montréal
alors c'est un édifice qui existe depuis
1967 c'était en fait l'ancien pavillon
des états unis qui a servi à accueillir
les visiteurs lors de l'exposition
universelle de 1967
ici à montréal et donc depuis quelques
années maintenant c'est devenu le musée
de l'environnement donc on va vous
montrer un petit peu à quoi ressemble ce
musée l'environnement parce que vous
n'avez peut-être pas eu la chance de
visiter cette espèce de musique est
unique en son genre en amérique du nord
par exemple vous avez plusieurs salles
comme ici vous avez un écran géant de
360 degrés qui vous montre un petit peu
quel est l'avenir de la planète
quelles sont les technologies qui vont
être utilisés pour essayer de réduire le
plus possible l'empreinte
environnementale donc c'est le genre de
musée qui vraiment donne toute la place
aux familles pour venir comprendre un
peu l'importance de l'environnement et
la protection évidemment de notre
planète ce sont les activités qui sont
présentés ici et qui l'année passée ont
accueilli 80 mille personnes des enfants
à partir de 10 ans
vous montrez une autre salle suivez moi
on va d'ailleurs salué mon caméraman
frédéric la selle qui me suis ici en
direct un peu partout à travers cet
édifice et on va entrer dans ce qu'on
appelle l'école a balance c'est un
laboratoire un peu pour les génies en
herbe ceux qui sont très curieux et ce
soir berre
on y trouve comme par magie le directeur
évidemment de la biosphère bonsoir jean
langlais alors d'abord expliquer moi un
petit peu ici on voit bon c'est une
salle de laboratoire avec des
microscopes dans le fond qu'est ce qu'on
peut apprendre ici qu'est ce qu'on
découvre c'est de mettre les gens c'est
vraiment expérience hier donc on veut
qu'ils découvrent la méthode
scientifique parce que lorsqu'on avance
quelque chose ça doit être basée sur des
faits sur la science donc c'est ce
qu'ils vont découvrir si l'hypothèse il
doit poser une hypothèse de départ donc
qu'est-ce qui le plus important la
pollution ou le p la pollution de l'air
ou de l'eau
donc ils ont des expériences doivent
expérimenter pendant quelques minutes
et finalement validé l'hypothèse de
départ est bon bien entendu qu'est ce
qui est mieux que ce qu'il perd la
pollution c'est pire en partant si ça ne
devrait jamais existé donc la pollution
de l'air influence sur la pollution de
l'eau et vice versa donc mais on veut
que les gens découvrent c'est quoi la
démarche scientifique
comment nos scientifiques travaillent
donc c'est ce qu'on fait ici pour onesta
traverse à mettre nos scientifiques en
valeur et la science environnement et
changement climatique selon l'eia
plusieurs salles ici dans ce musée je
lisais qui est assez unique dans
l'amérique du nord 1 vraiment musée de
l'environnement c'est le seul qui existe
complètement dédiée à l'environnement et
au changement climatique
alors on sait la protection de
l'environnement essayer de diminuer son
empreinte environnementale
c'est pas facile pour certaines villes
par exemple prenons l'exemple de
montréal tout le monde dit oui mais
comment ça se fait il ya la congestion
automobile
il ya du smig et de la pollution cd
grosse problématique qui touche les
villes d'un peu partout
et ici ce qu'on propose dans le fond
c'est de se mettre un peu à la place de
d'un maire ou de la mairesse de montréal
pour essayer de voir qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire c'est ça ça s'appelle planète
montréal a nettement rien n'est fait
donc il faut penser globalement je pense
que c'est important il faut
avoir une vision de l'avenir parce que
le changement climatique il est là donc
on doit y faire face
on doit composer avec on doit s'adapter
nous mais on doit atténuer ses effets
donc on présente la ville le milieu
urbain où vivent près de 85% la
population canadienne est en ville donc
une ville c'est comme un écosystème
ça doit avoir un équilibre cet
écosystème la vie avec d'autres
écosystèmes droit dont il est intact et
où il va impacter lui même s'était qui
les bloque on doit rechercher donc en
ville c'est important de prendre
conscience que chaque geste la façon
dont on agit on consomme on achète salon
un impact bien entendu surmultipliée du
fait du nombre de personnes qui y vivent
donc il faut penser globalement comment
vos colères comment va définir nos
quartiers du futur comment on voit la
ville de montréal l'aménager on peut pas
faire table rase à une ville qui est
justement donc ça c'est si la maquette
de la ville ici donc là c'est comme si
ceux qui viennent ici en fait c'est
comme si on leur donnait voici les clés
de la ville essayer de trouver des
solutions dans le fond c'est un peu ça
c'est un peu ça ils doivent se commettre
et bien entendu c'est c'est pas évident
c'est pas facile parce qu'il ya des
alliés les aléas de la vie de
l'environnement disons aujourd'hui il ya
une inondation donc vous êtes maire de
la ville vous devez composer avec ses
problèmes en plus vous voulez améliorer
la qualité de vie de votre vie vous
voulez que votre ville soit de plus en
plus durable via puis adorable aussi
parce qu'une ville ça doit être
intéressant donc comme maire vous êtes
confrontés à ces demandes à ses besoins
et à ses changements cette adaptation à
cette atténuation des impacts négatifs
on parle beaucoup des inondations de
plus en plus au printemps et au donc
comment aménager cette villa de sorte
que on soit l'homme moins impacté
négativement possible maintenant la peau
des élus on invite évidemment les
montréalais mais les gens d'un peu
partout au canada à venir justement
visiter ce musée pour voir un peu mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans le fond
à l'échelle humaine pour essayer de
réduire son empreinte c'est ça c'est le
gras du fait que l'anglais merci
beaucoup
en tout cas merci encore une fois de
nous accueillir on vous retrouvera
peut-être un peu plus tard donc dans ce
ce musée de l'environnement là il reste
quelques minutes maintenant un peu moins
de cinq minutes justement on va prendre
l'ascenseur si vous le voulez bien
on va au cinquième étage c'est là que
radio canada td a installé un studio
juste pour un soir on s'est vraiment un
studio éphémère où on va l'y retrouver
justement céline galipeau et ses invités
qui va nous présenter peut-être un petit
peu à quoi s'attendre justement ce soir
dans cette émission unique en son genre
une émission exceptionnelle donc qui
s'appelle 23h59 pour la planète
je voudrais d'ailleurs en profiter pour
saluer vous public qui nous suivaient
sur facebook live que ce soit au québec
au canada en amérique du nord
à l'autre bout du monde que ce soit en
asie en océanie ou en afrique merci de
nous suivre
et d'ailleurs je lance une invitation
pendant que l'on monte vous voyez en
arrière de moi la ville de montréal ici
alors qu'on remonte au 5e étage je vous
invite tout c'est tout à nous poser des
questions ou si vous avez des
commentaires par exemple sur ce que vous
faites vous personnellement pour essayer
de protéger les impacts sur la planète
est bien juste en dessous de cette
fenêtre là où je vous parle vous pouvez
bien sûr écrire des commentaires des
questions et pendant les pauses
publicitaires de cette émission on se
ferait plaisir d'essayer d'y répondre
avec les experts
les panélistes qui sont ici alors sans
plus attendre je vais maintenant vous
montrer à quoi ressemble alors qu'il
reste seulement trois minutes justement
le plateau je vais laisser frédéric
passé peut-être devant moi pour montrer
justement ce qui se passe ici dont voici
donc en exclusivité le plateau de minuit
moins une pour la planète
regardez il ya un public qui est ici
évidemment qui va écouter attentivement
les commentaires et les reportages qu'on
vous a présenté ce soir les reportages
qui je vous rappelle arrivent d'un peu
partout dans le monde et quelques
minutes avant que l'émission commence on
va parler tout de suite à céline qui est
maîtresse de cérémonie
ce soir d'abord pour les internautes
mettez nous un appétit là vous allez
nous faire voyager où on va aller
oui bonsoir tout le monde alors on va
voyager beaucoup parce qu on a mis nos
tous nos correspondants à l'étranger à
contribution donc on va aller notamment
dans les émirats arabes unis à dubaï
marie ève bédard ne montre une ville qui
a été ce qui est sortie du désert en
fait une ville verte autosuffisante
carboneutre enfin ça c'est intéressant
on est allé à oslo voir la capitale
verte de l'europe pour 2019
on va aussi aller faire un tour en
espagne jean françois bélanger nous
montre une petite ville qui a une assez
grosse ville quand même et qui a fermé
son centre ville aux voitures donc en
vous on essaie en fait de montrer des
solutions aux gens de ce qui marche
ailleurs et qui pourrait nous inspirer
ici donc on va se promener comme ça puis
à des exemples aussi ici vous même à
vivre par un reportage sur la
biométhanisation donc il ya des exemples
de solutions on en est rendu là je crois
quand on dit qu'il est minuit moins une
pour la planète c'est que les solutions
existent ces technologies sont là il
faut juste y aller je crois beaucoup de
contenu beaucoup d'idées qui vont
peut-être inspirer d'autres villes
d'autres pays justement qu'ils regardent
cette émission à travers facebook live
et vous avez bien sûr un panel important
d'éminents voilà les meilleurs donc leur
garidel alain webster et catherine
morency et puis étienne leblanc aussi
qui va en quelque sorte interagir avec
les internautes voilà l'aspect si les
environnements qui va donc répondre à
certaines questions à certains
commentaires qui vont être émis via le
web donc il reste une minute nous dit
diane c'est important donc on va se
retirer on va vous laisser vous préparez
donc je vous rappelle vous avez des
questions vous avez des commentaires des
idées d inspiration qui pourrait
peut-être faire avancer un peu les
choses en termes de protection de
l'environnement mais surtout vous
n'hésitez pas vous écrivez en bas de
cette fenêtre c'est très important et
pendant les pauses publicitaires
on va tenter d'y répondre avec donc le
panel avec les gens qui font partie de
cette émission donc ils restent là on va
dire 35 40 secondes avant le début de
l'émission dont il diffusé simultanément
sur ici radio canada délai est également
sur facebook live je termine en vous
montrant évidemment vous avez promis des
coulisses regardez ici on a installé de
toutes pièces ce qu'on appelle une régie
donc c'est ici un peu le cockpit de
l'avion de ce soir avec
nous avons martin marié qui est là qui
est un peu le chef d'orchestre de cela
on a immigrants di nisi qui donne un peu
les ce qu'on appelle les qte donc tous
les indices quand les émissions
recommence on également le 18 9 qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur le contenu de
cette émission
donc voilà c'est parti on vous laisse
comme ça
[Musique]
de parisot
pensez vous que la pollution soins
danger véritable
informés sur le sujet les mesures
annoncées encourageant l'utilisation
d'énergies polluantes et la construction
de nouvelles raffineries japonaises
essayer de développer notre faudra qu'on
s'y prenne et qu'on sépare les
spécialistes ont maintenant la preuve
dans la touche des jours les effets des
pluies acides sont plus graves qu'on y
croyez
le sommet de la terre de rio a terminé
ses travaux en adoptant une déclaration
visant une gestion durable de
l'environnement
plusieurs pays dont le canada ont signé
aujourd'hui le protocole de kyoto contre
le réchauffement de la planète
[Musique]
maison oui
et nous en sommes tous responsables de
80% des promesses qui ont été faites
n'ont jamais été tenues de moi que c'est
lamentable
[Musique]
mais bon quand
nourriture est officiellement de kyoto
pour les pollueurs justement le temps
pour ne pas redouter des inondations
historiques et le pire s'est produit au
lieu-dit expérience les phénomènes météo
extrêmes se sont multipliées c'était
très bien de la dernière vague de
chaleur au québec c'est bon de voir sur
quoi on sert ni le climat très lisse a
de la qualité
oc
je sais pas
austin
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir alors on
vient de le voir malgré des années de
négociation de sommets internationaux de
grande conférence sur le climat
on en est là il est minuit moins une
pour la planète
ce soir on vous convie à une grande
émission sur l'environnement nous allons
vous présenter des solutions un peu
partout sur la planète que nos
correspondants ont déniché et également
des portraits de citoyens engagés ici
donc des gens de chez nous j'ai aussi la
chance de m'entretenir avec nicolas
hulot le militant écologiste et ex
ministre français de l'environnement une
entrevue exclusive qu'il nous a accordé
chez lui en bretagne
je suis en compagnie d'experts qui vont
réagir tout au long de la soirée
mais vos réactions nous intéresse aussi
vous pouvez faire partie de la
discussion et nous poser vos questions
puisque nous sommes en direct sur
facebook
alors quel comportement êtes vous prêts
à changer ou pas pour la planète
exprimez-vous nous sommes ensemble pour
plus de deux heures et oui le
téléjournal sera exceptionnellement
présenté vers 22h15 alors bienvenue à
cette émission présentée en direct du
seul musée de l'environnement en
amérique du nord à la biosphère de
montréal
[Musique]
avec moi sur ce plateau ces experts dont
je vous parlais surtout des gens très
passionné leur varidel écosociologue
professeur associé à la chaire sur la
transition écologique de l'uqam
alain webster professeur en économie de
l'environnement à l'école de gestion de
l'université de sherbrooke et catherine
morency professeur titulaire à la chaire
mobilité à polytechnique montréal
bonsoir a tous droit
c'est un grand plaisir de vous avoir sur
ce plateau avec nous étienne leblanc mon
collègue spécialiste de l'environnement
ici à radio-canada van sant etienne sur
suivi alors on a choisi on a fait ce
choix éditorial ne pas être trop
alarmiste dans cette émission en fait on
voulait parler d'environnement de façon
plus positive qu'on le fait peut-être
général oui qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
parce que c'est vrai que si on écoute le
constat que nous font les scientifiques
après ce cas tous les jours du des
effets du changement climatique
ça peut paraître décourageant c'est un
défi énorme à surmonter
autant pour les citoyens que pour les
dirigeants politiques alors on peut en
parler différemment pour se motiver
peut-être le voir les bénéfices de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'air la
qualité de vie en général et même de
l'économie et donc c'est ce choix qu'on
a fait ce soir pour peut-être nous
motive et collectivement par faire un
pas vers l'avant plutôt que d'être
découragé donc c'est important de
changer de ton quand on parle
d'environnement catherine oui en fait on
le voit le constat est très claire les
solutions existent et quand on les met
en place les impacts attendus ce saveur
alors qu'ils sont venus mettre en place
et salue son foulée connaître donc franc
parler puis c'est aujourd'hui qu'ont
choisi ce qu'elle sera demain et on fait
ça parce qu'on veut créer une société
plus prospère plus riche plus équitable
plus compatibles avec ces enjeux
environnementaux c'est une très bonne
vue alors on y va on commence tout de
suite avec un des défis les plus
pressants auxquels la planète est
confrontée
parce que vous savez plus de la moitié
de la population mondiale vit déjà dans
des villes
bientôt ce seront deux personnes sur
trois et ses zones urbaines
elles émettent plus de 70% des émissions
globales de gaz à effet de serre alors
bien sûr l'idée d'une ville verte
carboneutre autosuffisante
ça fait rêver mais cette ville elles
existent déjà ou presque
on a visité
cette ville qui a poussé en plein désert
aux émirats arabes unis un projet
entièrement privé dans un pays de
pétrole
[Musique]
ma maman
des jardins luxuriants des étangs cette
vision qui se décline sur tons de vert
et de bleu que l'on découvre à vol
d'oiseau n'est pas celle à laquelle on
s'attend de dubaï plutôt connue pour son
climat désertique suffoquant bienvenue à
la sustainable city la ville durable
une communauté qui fait le pari
d'harnacher l'énergie solaire et de
réduire sa consommation énergétique
pour nous le but principal c'est de
devenir ce qu'on appelle un net zéro
énergie c'est à dire que toute la ville
la ville durable
nous aimerons nous aimerions produire de
l'électricité de l'énergie du soleil à
partir du soleil pour pour alimenter
toute la ville à 100%
quelques 26 mille panneaux solaires sont
distribués sur les toits de chacune des
500 villas des édifices publics et au
dessus des voitures dans les
stationnements chacun des aspects de la
construction des maisons réparties de
part et d'autre de ces rues parfaitement
paysager et entretenue a été pensé pour
minimiser l'impact du soleil et de la
chaleur qui peut facilement atteindre
les 50 degrés celsius ici orientation
plein nord aucune fenestration côté sud
vitrage anti-uv peinture réfléchissantes
tout ça permet à ces résidences de
consommer près de la moitié moins
d'énergie en climatisation qu'une
habitation moyenne à dubaï
les panneaux solaires qui sont installés
sur la terrasse fournissent aux
résidents entre 50 et 60% de l'énergie
dont ils ont besoin une économie
importante
cette villa au fait à sauver oui tonnes
de carbone sur une période de 18 mois
ce qui est pas mal ce qui est pas mal
alors si on utilise sa part 500 etc
ça commence à chiffrer rapidement dans
les rues les piétons et quelques vélos
sont rois les voitures sont interdites
et doivent rester au stationnement
communautaire la ville met à la
disposition des résidents des
voiturettes électriques
au début c'était un peu difficile parce
qu'on marche pas beaucoup à dubaï vous
savez au début c'est un peu choquant
spécialement quand ses 45 degrés d'or
mais ça va on s'habitue c'est le seul
petit sacrifice que je fais mais à part
ça au contraire je trouve que je je lis
une vie super belle ici
ce que j'ai gagné et fait beaucoup plus
que ce que j'ai perdu céline son mari
emmanuel et leurs deux jeunes garçons se
sont retrouvés à sustainable city après
plus d'une dizaine d'année à dubaï mais
cherchait une façon de vivre autrement
la chose que j'aime le plus ici c'est la
communauté j'ai rencontré tellement de
gens intéressants sympathie c'est ça la
différence aussi les gens qui qui qui
décident de vivre ici sont déjà
intéressés par ce sujet d'écologie
l'environnement qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour aider notre planète j'ai
rempli ma bouteille dacquoise ozone
papier plastique dans les petits gestes
du quotidien céline a le sentiment de
pouvoir faire sa part pour freiner
l'effet des gaz à effet de serre sur
notre planète sur l'avenir de ses
enfants quand on parle de tout ce qui
est de développement durable il faut
vraiment pas il faut penser en société
il faut pas il faut penser toujours en
communauté ce n'est pas l'individu elle
l'un vie de l'individu peut faire peut
faire beaucoup de choses mais c'est
c'est la communauté qui peut faire
davantage de choses ensemble
et alors si ça qu'on essaie de créer
sous chacun de ces dom la ville produit
des laitues des légumes et des herbes
qui sont distribués aux résidents
l'irrigation se fait avec les eaux usées
et recycler sur place on ne rien
gaspiller ici occupé à pleine capacité
sustainable city se concentrent sur
l'avenir
ses promoteurs veulent en faire un
centre mondial d'innovation des
technologies environnementales
c'est empilables c'est à dire que c'est
comme des boîtes de lego georges
beaudoin est à grenoble chez agri coule
une jeune entreprise française qui veut
révolutionner l'agriculture en milieu
urbain avec ces conteneurs recyclés dont
la température et la luminosité sont
contrôlés pour y cultiver des fruits et
légumes à l'année ici ils produisent de
la fraise
c'est qu'on a vraiment le temps
d'attenté lors des récoltes à maturité
et on importe du coup aux consommateurs
quelques heures après la fraise mûre
deux jours des fraises qui goûte l'été
sur toute une année une promenade au
bord d'un étang près duquel se reposent
des canards des rues où les enfants
règne le silence et une bonne conscience
une oasis une ville à échelle humaine
mais ce petit paradis est il à la portée
de tous
le développement durable doit toucher
tout le monde je pense plus qu'on a un
choix ce n'est pas le luxe qu'on essaie
de vendre si c'est la durabilité qu'on
essaie de l'ombre est alors pour que la
vie durables soient accessibles à à tout
le monde il faut que le coup le coût de
tout ce qu'on voit ici autour de nous
baisse
pour moi personnellement le concept de
vivre dans une communauté qui est en
train de faire une différence
ça valait la peine et je n'ai jamais
regretté ça mais oui il faut être riche
parce que ce qu'on paie là pour ceux
qu'on a un
on pourrait avoir beaucoup de russes
avec seront paix ou la même chose pour
moi beaucoup moins cher mais la qualité
de vie est incomparable la qualité de
vie mais ce qu'on vienne voir n'est sans
doute pas un modèle très réaliste pour
nous le défi c'est plutôt d'adapter nos
villes qui sont déjà construites de
mettre en place les infrastructures et
les technologies pour leur permettre de
se développer de façon durable
c'est ce que tente de faire oslo la
capitale de la norvège
élue ville verte de l'europe cette année
l'objectif est très ambitieux même dans
l'un des pays les plus verts de la
planète
oslo ne se donne que quelques années
pour devenir carboneutre
c'est à dire réduire le plus possible
ses émissions de co2 et trouver des
façons de compenser pour ce qui sera
quand même rejeté dans l'atmosphère
[Musique]
pour arriver à concocter cette recette
sous a réuni les meilleurs ingrédients
l'objectif changer les habitudes de vie
de ses habitants
pour y arriver il faut d'abord réduire
les distances nécessaires au déplacement
oslo au vu des quartiers denses et
compactes dans lesquelles les résidents
peuvent rapidement trouver tout ce dont
ils ont besoin pour les déplacements ce
qu'on vous souhaite que ça se passe dans
un esprit de mobilité verte c'est-à-dire
marché faire du vélo entre le train et
le tramway ou encore l'autobus les
moyens de transport qu'ils ne devront
plus produire aucun gaz à effet de serre
d'ici une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
c'est bien clair les automobilistes ne
sont pas les bienvenus ici au centre
ville d'oslo
pour y entrer avec une voiture il faut
payer et puis des centaines de places de
stationnement ont carrément disparu
remplacées par des espaces publics
mais attention la voiture conserve sa
place à oslo ce qu'on ne veut plus ce
sont des véhicules qui polluent la ville
fait non beaucoup pour attirer les
voitures électriques jusqu'à leur
aménager des stationnements sous terre
autre ingrédient essentiel pour devenir
une véritable ville verte s'attaquer à
la consommation d'énergie de ces
édifices
les anciens comme les nouveaux
[Musique]
cette école par exemple a été construite
avec les meilleures techniques et les
technologies vertes de pointe
l'édifice est si bien isolé si bien
orientée pour profiter du soleil qu'il
produit plus d'électricité qu'elle n'en
consomme
ici les autorités jouent dur elles ne
font pas que souhaité des changements
elle en impose également avec des lois
parfois très strictes
même les déchets ménagers ont leur place
dans cette recette imaginée à oslo si on
insiste beaucoup sur le recyclage et le
compostage est sûre ça permet d'éviter
des émissions de méthane dans les sites
d'enfouissement
et surtout ce qui n'est pas enfoui peut
être transformés en engrais par exemple
ou encore en carburant ce qui ne peut
pas être transformés et brûlé
cette chaleur et chauffe de l'eau par
des tuyaux elle réchauffe les
appartements et puis oslo espère capter
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
provenant de ces incinérateurs pour les
enfouir dans seule façon de s'assurer
qu'elle ne contribue pas aux
bouleversements climatiques
[Musique]
ou bien réussir sa recette oslo et tuent
les aussi des ingrédients qui sont
parfois difficiles à trouver
d'abord des citoyens et des élus motivés
et aussi beaucoup d'argent l'ironie
c'est qu'une partie des millions de
dollars qui financent ces technologies
vertes est en fait de la vente de
pétrole de gaz naturel les sources
d'énergie ils sont loin d'être aussi
proche
c'est fascinant quand même alors vous
qu'est ce que vous retenez d'importance
qui pourrait nous inspirer ici en tout
cas on le voit quand on donne les moyens
aux gens on peut changer les
comportements confirme encore une fois
que les solutions existent et que
beaucoup de concepts qu'on connaît
depuis des années et quand ils sont mis
en application est véritablement des
gens qui vont les adoptés qu'ils exigent
en fait on ya vraiment une demande
latente pour ce petit de quartiers dans
lesquels on veut redonner le quartier
aux citoyens et citoyennes pour quelques
s'approprier les rues et avoir une
meilleure qualité lui on voit que ça
effectivement des effets très positifs
j'ai un peu mieux et en fait que je
pourrais dire c'est que l'on voit
totalement la mise en application de
quelque chose qui est bien connu dans
notre domaine qui sont les cinq des onze
les voit apparaître les cinq décès
comment on fait pour développer des bons
quartiers un des quartiers danses des
quartiers avec une diversité d'usagés on
a parlé de proximité de courtes
distances pour accepter aux destinations
aux gouvernants un accès à plusieurs
types de destinations
on parle de distances courtes aux
transports en commun et on parle de
désert dans la façon dont on conçoit nos
intersection la proximité entre
intersections et où on qu'ils ont
vraiment fait une mise en application
plus d'autres concepts évidemment qu'on
connaît bien mais on voit que les
citoyens c'est pas ils ne sont pas en
prison ils ont l'air tout à fait heureux
ils adoptent ce qui leur a été offert
donc c'est urgent nous qu'on fasse la
même chose
oui urgents vers ça prend quand même un
cadre non alain ça prend une volonté
collective oui des citoyens mais ça
prend aussi une volonté politique de
faire à la fois un appui des citoyennes
dans un bouge pas du tout mais en même
temps les actions politiques et actions
politiques qui se font de deux façons un
cadre réglementaire voici une obligation
on abolit par exemple usage du pétrole
dans le chauffage du bâtiment de 2 face
au québec.le plusieurs années entre
ici on va le chauffage des maisons au
mazout vers le volet électricité pas
complet mais on a déjà bougé l'aide donc
un cadre réglementaire global sur
plusieurs éléments et en même temps un
ensemble d'instruments économiques c'est
là qu'on retrouve la taxe carbone la
plus élevée au monde qui vont orienter
cette prise de décision individuelle
pour les citoyens mais également pour
les entreprises
et ça nous permet d'atteindre des cibles
de réductions les plus élevés sur la
planète ils sont les plus ambitieux est
ce qui est passionnant
lorsqu'on regarde ce qu'on fait au
québec mais on a tout pour réussir à
faire un modèle tout aussi exemplaire
ici et dans quelques années les gens
vont se demander est-ce qu'on va
montréal ou à oslo pour faire ces
modèles exemple pourquoi on n'est pas
rendu là
pourquoi on le fait pas parce que c'est
compliqué réussir à faire cette prise de
décision simultanément parce que les
gens ont l'impression qu'ils vont perdre
quelque chose on a l'impression que ce
sera encore une espèce de rêve qu'on va
nous inventer
on n'est pas sûr qu'on obtiendra ce gars
là et en même temps pour plusieurs
personnes ces questions de changements
climatiques sont un peu compliquées à
comprendre ça reste un peu loin on a
l'impression que c'est pas l'homme
maintenant alors que pour l'instant on
vit déjà les conséquences
c'est pour ça que ça presse mais dans
les villes d'amérique du nord dont les
villes qui sont peut-être plus ancienne
et qui sont déjà construites à l'eau
restait des choses qu'on peut faire
assez rapidement assez concrètement
facilement que oui il ya des choses qui
se font déjà grâce à la pression
citoyenne grâce à des partis politiques
qui parfois décide de passer de la
parole aux actes pour le vit dans
certains quartiers de montréal dans
certaines municipalités au québec où
chaque fois qu'on rénove une rue par
exemple on décide d'agrandir l'espace
piéton de planter des arbres d'accorder
plus de place à la mobilité durable qui
contribue à une meilleure santé aussi
des citoyens citoyennes meilleure
qualité de vie mais c'est clair que les
politiciens ne bouge pas les citoyens
bouge pas non plus et il y a de la place
pour l'innovation et je pense qu'au
québec maintenant on est prêts à aller
plus loin qu'on l'était il ya quelques
années on est beaucoup plus conscients
qu'il ya quelques années et ça peut être
un facteur de développement économique
oui je crois que c'est transformer nos
villes d'art te fais je crois que c'est
ça qui doit arriver en fait c'est que le
gouvernement les gouvernements les
décideurs politiques voient ces
changements commune
dépenses évidemment ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent réaménager des villes refaire
les quartiers les rend plus sécuritaire
pour les cyclistes les piétons chez des
rats c'est beaucoup d'investissement et
on a parfois l'impression que des gouver
des décideurs politiques voient ça comme
une dépense alors que des exemples comme
oslo mais quand je suis comme ça aussi
oui c'est vrai qu'on attend comme ça
mais il ya plein d'exemples quand je
suis seul ou en france les villes de
taille moyenne ont tous libérés leur
centre-ville des voitures et aujourd'hui
elles vont très bien au point de vue
économique la qualité de vie a augmenté
la qualité de l'air à augmenter et donc
tout est positif et à moyen terme n'est
même pas juste à long terme à moyen
terme
c'est un investissement donc c'est
gagnant gagnant pour le monde
maintenant mes collègues animateurs de
la semaine verte de rdi économie la
météo de découverte se joignent
également à nous ce soir pour partager
leurs réflexions face au climat
alors écoutons d'abord charles tisseyre
[Musique]
depuis la naissance de la terre il ya
quatre milliards 500 millions d'années
il ya eu cinq extinctions de masse la
plus connue est celle qui a mis fin au
règne des dinosaures il ya 65 millions
d'années
chaque fois la terre sont étirées mais
il faut savoir qu'il y à 252 millions
d'années notre planète a failli mourir
la pire extinction de masse de son
histoire a vu disparaître
96 % de toutes les espèces marines et 70
% des espèces terrestres
cet événement catastrophique appelé
extinction de masse permien trias a été
causées par d'importantes d'éruption
volcanique en sibérie qui ont projeté
des grandes quantités de co2 dans
l'atmosphère selon une recherche publiée
début décembre dans science
ce phénomène a causé une augmentation
importante de la température de
l'atmosphère et de l'océan
et puisque l'eau plus chaude ne peut pas
contenir autant d'oxygène que l'eau
froide
c'est par asphyxie que de nombreuses
espèces marines sont mortes
ces chercheurs de l'université de
washington ont découvert que cette
extinction de masse se déployer sur à
peine quelques milliers d'années
un clin d'oeil à l'échelle géologique il
croit que cet événement est riche
d'enseignements parce que le système
terre réagi aujourd'hui à l'augmentation
de co2 de la même façon que dans le
passé l'atmosphère se réchauffe
enocean a déjà accusé une diminution de
son taux d'oxygène de l'ordre de 2%
depuis 50 ans le plus en plus de
scientifiques estiment que l'homme est
maintenant à l'origine d'une sixième
extinction
il est clair que si nous ne réussissons
pas à maîtriser nos émissions de co2 et
que nous exploitons toutes les réserves
restent hors d'énergie fossile les
conséquences pour la vie sur terre
pourraient être désastreuses
vous mettez pas dans la même situation
si vous pensez vous avez une branche it
out ou si vous avez un cancer mais en
face de métastases et la planète est
dans une situation de ce cancer très
avancé
[Musique]
ok alors donc on continue bien sûr cette
émission pas de pauses publicitaires sur
facebook live on a tout à les voir
étienne leblanc justement qui continuent
de répondre justement questions des
internautes et merci d'ailleurs de nous
envoyer vos questions en direct juste en
dessous de cette fenêtre sur facebook
live d'abord etienne il ya carole picard
qui se demandent ils aimeraient savoir
si les automobiles électriques pollue
plus à construire qu'une automobile à
moteur il dit que plusieurs pensent que
oui alors quelle est la réalité c'est
effectivement quand on analyse le cycle
de vie de la construction d'une voiture
électrique
effectivement les effets sur
l'environnement sont loin d'être nul
parce que bien entendu bon une voiture
électrique c'est le même métal
l'aluminium toutes les composantes mais
en plus la fameuse pile et les piles de
voitures électriques
elles ont besoin de métaux rares qu'on
va chercher dans des mines à gauche et à
droite sur la planète et ça ça a des
conséquences réelles sur l'environnement
maintenant il faut voir les effets aussi
à plus long terme qu'est ce qu'on
cherche avec la voiture électrique est
ce qu'on cherche à réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre à la source
quand les voitures roulent sur la route
il est vrai que maintenant une voiture
électrique et même pas de gaz à effet de
serre quand une fois calé sur la route
mais sont les effets sur l'environnement
ne sont pas nulles au contraire donc
c'est loin d'être la solution c'est
peut-être même une transition vers un
modèle où les voitures il y aura des
flottes de voitures où vous n'aurez pas
vous ne serez pas propriétaire d'une
voiture vous même et vous utilisez donc
des voitures de flotte qui viendront
vous chercher votre maison et vous
transporteront là vous voulez ali alors
on a beaucoup de questions venant faire
un maximum question maintenant de ain
côtés qui nous suivent sur facebook on
parle beaucoup de batteries de panneaux
solaires qu'est ce qui arrive après la
vie utile de ceci ou de celle ci qu'est
ce qui arriva ses batteries ou à ses
panneaux solaires
très bonne question et ça c'est un enjeu
je crois qu'il pour lesquels on n'a pas
encore de solution parfaite
les panneaux solaires très très bonne
question parce que
on a comme le nucléaire c'est écologique
jusqu à un certain point mais après il
des déchets disons que les effets de des
déchets ne sont pas les mêmes quand même
que le nucléaire mais c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas encore trouvé les moyens de
complètement recycler toutes les
composantes de ces choses là et batterie
encore moins les panneaux solaires il ya
déjà des gens qui planchent là dessus
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec ses
panneaux solaires qu'on va retrouver
notamment en chine mais de plus en plus
partout dans le monde alors ça c'est ce
sont de vraies questions auxquelles il
faudra s'intéresser le plus vite
possible
autre question de nelly brière on parle
beaucoup des gens qui évidemment
prennent l'avion on peut racheter des
crédits de carbone est ce que ça c'est
efficace est ce que c'est fiable
les outils de calcul sont encore affiner
mais il ya de plus en plus d'organismes
qui ont des outils de calcul de plus en
plus précis et en général les
organisations qui nous offre de
compenser les crédits les le lys le co2
les émissions plante des arbres et donc
les arbres c'est un puits de carbone ça
absorbe le co2 c'est un peu comme ça que
ça fonctionne vous en était dans l'avion
et les arbres absorbent mais ça reste à
raffiner quand même comme outil et c'est
quelque chose qui va se développer
certainement de plus en plus avec tous
les voyages qui sont aujourd'hui trois
minutes 33 réponse est excellent merci
beaucoup et tiennent donc on va laisser
se poursuivre bien sûr cette émission en
direct en même temps sur facebook live
mais également sur ici radio canada télé
d'autres reportages d'un peu partout
dans le monde et puis toujours vos
questions vos commentaires et vos idées
d'inspiration pour mieux réduire notre
empreinte environnementale et bien c'est
en bas de cette fenêtre facebook live on
répond aux questions la prochaine pause
[Musique]
je vous le disais tout à l'heure cette
émission vous est présentée en direct de
la biosphère et ce n'est pas un hasard
c'est que cet édifice emblématique de
montréal est vraiment le seul musée
l'environnement en amérique du nord
alors on l'a gramercy d'ailleurs de nous
accueillir si généreusement ici ce soir
alors c'est un bâtiment vert grâce à la
géothermie et aux éoliennes est aussi un
magnifique mur vert de plantes des
mesures dont qui permettent de réduire
son empreinte écologique
justement ça nous amène à nous
questionner sur notre propre empreinte
sébastien desrosiers donc comment est-ce
qu'on calcule notre poids écologique
voilà d'abord ses livres qu'est ce que
c'est que l'empreinte écologique si vous
voulez c'est un peu la surface de la
planète nécessaire pour supporter notre
mode de vie autrement dit la terre l'eau
l'air nécessaire pour produire les biens
qu'on consomme et d'autre part les
déchets assimilés les déchets qu'on
produit alors pour la calculer cette
empreinte un outil ce quiz de global
footprint network aussi disponible en
français voici quelques-unes des
questions auxquelles vous devrez
répondre d'abord sur l'alimentation est
ce que vous consommez des produits
animaux ils ont une empreinte écologique
plus importante que les végétaux mais
aussi du risque d'où proviennent les
aliments que vous consommez mieux vaut
consommer local bien sûr aussi sur le
logement est ce que vous habitez dans un
manoir dans une maison ou encore dans un
appartement à plus la surface est
importante plus il ya des pertes
d'énergie qu'on peut compenser soit dit
en passant avec de l'électricité de
source renouvelable comme c'est le cas
au québec
vos déchets est-ce que vous en avez plus
ou moins que vos voisins comparer pour
le plaisir de le faire et puis les
transports est ce que vous empruntez les
transports en commun est ce que vous
prenez l'avion qui est un mode de
transport polluants tout ça ça va vous
donner un résultat en nombre de planètes
autrement dit si tout le monde
consommait comme vous de combien de
planète terre aurions nous besoin et ça
bien si la moyenne canadienne
l'une des pires au monde et si comme
nous vous vous sentez un peu coupable la
baie sachez que vous pouvez compenser
vos émissions de co2 en achetant des
crédits carbone comme sur compensation
co2 québec c'est ce que nous avons fait
pour compenser les vols d'avions de
nos correspondants cadre de l'émission
et alors ça a coûté 2 102 122 dollars
voilà pour cent mille kilomètres quand
même parcours en avion c'est pas de
temps mais enfin c'est tout une veille
de nos consciences merci à sébastien
vous en prie comme dans la plupart des
pays industrialisés les transports dont
sans doute une des sources les plus
importantes d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ici au canada les transports
arrive au deuxième rang après
l'exploitation pétrolière et gazière au
québec c'est la source la plus
importante qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
bien jean françois bélanger s'est rendu
à pontevedra en espagne une ville à peu
près de la taille de drummondville 80000
habitants à peu près où on a fait preuve
vous allez voir d'audace
c'est à première vue une petite ville de
galice sans histoire une ville médiévale
sur le chemin de compostelle où l'on
passait sans s'arrêter
mais aujourd'hui ponte vedra est devenu
un modèle que beaucoup tentent de copier
ici pas de congestion pas de klaxon pas
de pollution à pontevedra
le piéton est roi l'architecte du
changement c'est luis miguel angel
fernandez élu maire de la ville
en 1999 on a entrepris de transformer
complètement ses principes à savoir
qu'apple fait nul contre avant 14 mille
voitures passaient dans cette rue chaque
jour il a profile la place à l'espagne
la base sur la place d'espagne il en
passe et 28000 c'était davantage que sur
la voie de contournement de l'autoroute
c'était bastia en quelques mois
les voitures sont chassés du centre
ville les rues deviennent piétonnes la
circulation automobile est réduite de
90%
ponte vedra est transfiguré
[Musique]
ici il y avait auparavant un bruit
constant de klaxon les gens coincés dans
les embouteillage de s'énerver et
klaxonnaient il tournait en rond sans
fin la recherche d'un stationnement
je pense que les gens sont plus heureux
maintenant les voitures n'ont pas
totalement disparu de pontevedra
mais tout est fait pour limiter l'usagé
à ce qui est vraiment essentiel
les livraisons par exemple et le
stationnement est strictement
réglementée 15 minutes maximum
tout dépassement de la période autorisée
et sévèrement punis 150 dollars damant à
l'entrée de la ville d'immenses
stationnements gratuits ont été
installés les gens venant de l'extérieur
sont invités à laisser leur voiture et
ont continué leur chemin à pied
c'est ce que fait désormais chaque matin
susanna otero alvarez une promenade
santé de 15 minutes
intégré dans sa routine quotidienne et
qu'elle apprécie génial de pouvoir
marcher dans le centre de pontevedra
avec des enfants sans se préoccuper des
voitures ça me donne un vrai sentiment
de sécurité
c'est génial est pas là dans les rues
des panneaux semblables à des plans de
métro indique le temps nécessaire pour
se rendre à destination
la mesure a fonctionné au delà de toute
espérance
aujourd'hui les deux tiers des
déplacements en ville ce fonds soit à
pied soit à vélo ce qui a permis de
réduire les émissions de co2 de 75%
a ponte vedra même là où circulent les
voitures
le piéton est désormais au centre des
priorités tout a été repensé en
conséquence la vitesse limitée à 20 ou
30 km heure et les passages piétons ont
été surélevés pour forcer les voitures à
ralentir
résultat depuis la transformation de la
ville le nombre d'accidents mortels a
été divisée par dix et aucun décès n'est
à déplorer
au cours des sept dernières années la
mesure a aussi permis de redynamiser le
centre ville qui a accueilli en quelques
années
douze mille nouveaux habitants les rues
ils sont plus animée et les commerçants
s'estime gagnant coachée par comment une
ville sans voitures c'est positif pour
le commerce
ça donne une meilleure ambiance pour
faire des achats sans la pression des
voitures sans la fumée c'est beaucoup
plus agréable réticents les habitants de
ponte vedra sont aujourd'hui plus que
convaincu le maire miguel hernandez
vient d'être réélu pour un quatrième
mandat
ce qui me satisfait le plus c'est
l'orgueil que ressentent les habitants
qui ont l'impression de vivre dans la
meilleure ville au monde et les
chaussures à la mode mais le travail est
loin d'être terminé
la ville est un chantier perpétuel de
plus en plus de russes ont transformé à
la demande des citoyens et pontevedra
est devenu une référence mondiale
un modèle bientôt copié par madrid la
capitale et plus de 130 villes à travers
l'espagne
alors catherine réaction est ce qu il se
pourrait se faire vous voyez en fait
clairement que ça s'applique peut-être
pas à cette échelle là immédiatement
avec des étapes dans les plantations de
ces stratégies l'homme et on le fait
déjà à petite échelle et pas seulement
dans les quartiers centraux il ya des
petites municipalités dans les
territoires depuis aubin qui vont
implanter les petites zones de rencontre
on expérimente vraiment ces nouvelles
stratégies de combinaison des différents
flux mais de façon fondamentale
ça indique qu'il faut réfléchir à la
location des espaces dans nos milieux de
vie parce qu'ils sont à la base des
milieux de vie faut concilier le besoin
de qualité de vie avec le besoin de
mobilité
il faut aussi réaliser qu'un grand rôle
qu'ils peuvent jouer par la mobilité
active c'est vraiment fondamental de
réfléchir et surtout le mérite et active
mobilité la marche et le vélo est un je
sais que ça peut être plus des primaires
de dire ceci est le meilleur le pire
choix qu'on peut faire en termes de
capacité de transport de personnes c'est
de dédier une voix l'automobile parce
que c'est celle qui a la moindre
capacité et si vous regardez la
congestion généralement ce qui crée la
condition ce sont des sièges vides en
grande majorité ce qui crée la
congestion
ce sont des sièges mais parce que les
gens sont tolérants 1.17 me demander
c'est pas des morceaux jazz et en fait
c'est vraiment réallouer l'espace il
dédié des voies réservées au transport
en commun d'année des espaces aux vélos
et aux piétons pour augmenter la
capacité de déplacement tout en étant
plus conciliable avec lille souhaite
avoir des bons milieux de vie on voit
les gens ont l'air tout à fait heureux
c'est encore une fois ce n'est pas la
catastrophe mais il faudrait dix ils ont
paré est ce qu'on vit ici parce qu'ici
on a quand même
d'abord à cause du du temps non le
climat le j'ai toujours dit c'est une
question d'expérience à tout fonctionne
très bien bon et quand il fait moins 40
avec la mer tout le monde devrait rester
à la maison
mais le travail
oui totalement mais quand même on a un
rapport très affectif halle avec la
voiture comment jean lannes aura du mal
à imaginer de ne pas vivre de vivre sans
voiture volée mais dépend dans la
voiture on est dans une culture de
voitures maintenant je pense qu'il faut
se poser la question quand on entendre
on s'entend nous mêmes dit j'ai besoin
d'une voiture est ce qu'il s'est
vraiment d'une voiture dont on a besoin
ou c'est avant tout deux dépassé du
point a au point b
le vrai besoin c'est un besoin de
mobilité est ce qu'on peut trouver un
moyen plus efficace de se déplacer et
même plus économique parce que si on
regarde globalement combien d'argent on
dépense en moyenne dans les familles au
québec pour la voiture et il est bien
c'est le deuxième poste de dépense à
passe tout de suite après le logement et
avant l'alimentation pour quelque chose
qui est stationné en moyenne au québec
95 % du temps 95 chaleur pensons à tout
l'espace de nos villes qui est dédié
partout qui est dédié à du stationnement
qui pourrait être occupé par des espaces
verts ce qui contribue davantage à la
qualité de l'air - claude challe à
l'arrêt devant pedro we had jardinage
urbain aussi à une meilleure qualité de
vie pour tous ça rendrait nous nos
villes beaucoup plus agréable mais ça se
fait étape par étape et je pense qu'il
faut d'abord prendre conscience qu'un
moyen de faire les choses autrement oui
mais on peut penser de la transport en
commun ouais puis d'autres de donner un
moyen mais quand même il ya des gens qui
vivent dans des régions éloignées et des
gens qui vivent en banlieue et des gens
qui vivent et qui disait nous c'est bien
beau ce que vous dites là pas de voiture
mais nous on en a besoin on a besoin
pour travailler pour aller travailler
pour des déplacements qui peut se faire
avec un autre mode c'est clair et en
fait on a la chance maintenant d'avoir
dit des technologiques peuvent offrir ou
permettre d'offrir du transport en
commun nouveau de nouveaux types parce
qu'on ne peut plus imaginer la ligne
d'autobus 6 à des heures spécifiques
avec un gros véhicule
maintenant on peut développer des
systèmes de transport à la demande dans
lequel même dans les territoires peu
denses même avec une demande des
placements plus diffuse et l'on peut
offrir des services collectifs
il faut aussi réaliser que je pense pas
que ce qu'on veut c'est obliger tout le
monde à posséder un véhicule pour
pouvoir se déplacer cette notion de
dépendance elle va dans tous les sens la
relation affective mais aussi des gens
qui voudraient pouvoir faire d'autres
choix il faut les offrir et ces
technologies nous est maintenant offrir
des nouveaux types de transports en
commun qu'ont mené avec par exemple des
services de véhicules partagés où les
gens peuvent voir prêter le véhicule
pour la durée pour la durée requise et
faire leurs déplacements donc avoir un
ensemble de la voyance oui en fait la g
on dit souvent l'avenir c'est des
véhicules partagés électrique connecté à
c'est ça qui va nous permettre d'offrir
la mobilité un peu partout dans ma
cabine et a dit que vos services de
transport en commun car la demande est
suffisante
mais l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir une
utilisation de tous ces modes la marche
certainement le vélo les modes partager
et le transport en commun lentement mais
ça prend des véhicules plus performants
on parle de voitures électriques je vous
ai entendu vous que j'ai aussi entendu
critiquer un peu en voiture électrique
est ce que c'est là ce que c'est la
solution
il y aura également des véhicules plus
performant c'est clair en matière de
consommation il y aura d'abord du
transport en commun qui vont nous
permettre de faire des gains économiques
en matière de réduction du coût de la
congestion par exemple en augmentant la
valeur des actifs
on le voit même à montréal lorsqu'on
construit drm on sait que les bâtiments
autour valent plus cher on peut même
leur imposer un surcoût donc là on voit
qu on augmente ce gain économique par
ses infrastructures
on sait qu'on fait des gains en santé
majeur donc une réduction de dépenses
c'est fondamental mais au-delà de ce
transport en commun et de ce transport
actif il va rester encore pendant
plusieurs années des personnes qui vont
se déplacer sur une base individuelle on
le voit bien en espagne avec leur
voiture on a installé des stationnements
incitatifs en bordure de la ville les
gens qui vont y arrivent en voiture mais
on espère que ça sera en voiture
électrique ou en tout cas avec des
voitures beaucoup plus performante du
point de vue des carburants parce qu'on
aura réglementer ces carburants
parce qu'on aurait imposé une
tarification carbone plus élevés et
parce qu'on aura incité le développement
de biocarburants dont six véhicules
automobiles auront d'empreinte
environnementale plus faible en matière
de jeux s c'est fondamental et c'est la
combinaison tout ça qu'ils vont nous
permet de gagner
oui c'est les voitures électriques oui
en fait moi j'allais dire on a une
politique sur la mobilité dans lequel on
parle de réduire transférer et améliorer
c'est dans le sens dans lequel ça doit
se faire c'est à dire d'abord réduire le
nombre de véhicules réduire le recours
aux véhicules privés ensuite transféré
donc libre déplacement les mettre dans
un mode qui plus durable et ensuite pour
les déplacements qui doivent être faites
mobile il faut il écrit ou prendre des
véhicules plus petits parce qu'on a
vraiment un phénomène ce soit agréable
de toute façon on va pas on veut pas
convaincre les gens de changer de mode
de transport dans cette société qui est
tellement centré sur la voiture si on à
l'offre si on ne leur offre pas
d'alternative des alternatives donc sont
abordables qui coûte pas trop cher pas
plus cher on espère surtout efficace et
confortable confortable parce que si on
en sort on va de la voiture à la classe
sardines dans le métro des gens vont pas
le faire et donc ça demande des
investissements importants et on
n'arrive pas à rentrer dans le métro
sont je reviens ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il faut pas voir ça comme une
dépense mais comme un investissement
évidemment ça nécessite beaucoup du fond
ça c'est sûr mais si tout le monde
avance dans la même direction
on pourra y arriver c'est faisable qui
en plus au québec on construit les
traits ont construit des autos 200 e
tout intérêt à investir collectivement
dans le transport en commun et aussi en
région quand on dit débarrassé la
voiture d'une posture pas plus avant de
voitures du tout mais certains ménages
peut-être passer de trois voitures à
deux voitures ou de 2,2 à une sphère de
l'autopartage ou de faire sa demande
vraiment l'adaptation wii ça demande un
changement de paradigme en fait il faut
revoir comment est-ce qu'on habite notre
planète et comment on répond à des
besoins mobilité ça peut vouloir dire
aussi choisir où on habite en partant en
lien avec notre milieu travail l'école
de nos enfants l'on peut obtenir des
services grand changement de société
mais pour le mieux pour lui mais entre
temps les sens qu'on met dans nos
voitures qu'on utilise encore le pétrole
qu'on consomme il vient surtout de
l'amérique du nord de l'alberta
notamment mais même au pays des sables
bitumineux les mentalités commencent à
changer on vous présente maintenant le
travail d'une jeune militante
autochtones ou aller voir une femme
inspirée et inspirante
bonjour je m'appelle mélina l'avocat de
masse est mort je suis créé
là bas ça
les familles
son manager et enrico nsonwu manager je
peux pas croire qu'ils peuvent pas
prendre des actions pour arrêter nous
met en danger
ça donne un point d'entrée à toute une
génération pour saisir dénoncer ma cause
ils vont mal est vrai pas mon ami
[Musique]
on dirait que beaucoup de questions dire
continuez de nous écrire aux questions
dans la barre de commentaires en dessous
de la vidéo j'ai à mes côtés ici une des
panélistes catherine morency en une
question ici on va rester dans le
domaine des voitures
adam adam jouette jouini qui demande
c'est quoi les avancées technologiques
pour la voiture à hydrogène on sait que
ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle avec
about the works a mis son nez ou cette
affaire-là spécialiste de la technologie
hydrogène je sais pas c'est indécent
mais placés que moi pour en parler mais
notre directeur de polytechnique et un
grand défendeur de cette technologie est
en fait je pense que c'est une des
façons de rendre le véhicule électrique
parce que c'est fou comme source
d'énergie stockée leur emploi mais comme
je connais peu ça je pourrais pas vous
parler bien en détails de ce qui se
développe c'est un peu c'est un peu mis
de côté pour l'instant on va dire c'est
plus électriques les hybrides beaucoup
autre question maintenant de max eric
une question pour alain webster ici
professeur à l'université de sherbrooke
bonsoir on paie une taxe de 10 max eric
sur le carbone depuis 2008
qu'est ce qu'ils font avec cet argent ça
c'est un financier le fonds vert
l'ensemble des revenus obtenus au québec
à travers ce système de permis
d'émissions échangeables donc il y aura
en place et la taxe carbone
lorsqu'on a mis en place un système de
bourse carbone l'ensemble de ces fonds
sont dédiés au fond vert et par la loi
on a l'obligation dans le fond vert de
dépenser litres environ les deux tiers
de cette somme dans le volet transports
ensuite c'est une stratégie qui sert à
financer l'ensemble des mesures de
conversion vers une économie
décarbonisée et ses claques se font la
voir faire l'objet d'une discussion dans
les prochains mois puisque on se demande
si on pourrait peut être plus efficace
dans la façon de le louer ces fonds en
même temps c'est compliqué parce qu'on
doit faire deux choses réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
en même temps trouver une façon de
s'adapter à ce climat qui change et
trouver une façon de compenser ses coûts
économiques associés à cette
modification du climat est donc une
question c'est est-ce que ses revenus
ces fonds doivent provenir du fonds vert
ou doivent provenir d'autres qu'on
appelle le fonds consolidé
mais ce qui est passionnant c'est que
c'est une d un des rares sources de
revenus au québec qui est dédié un objet
spécifique la protection de
l'environnement
donc juste ça c'est un gain
extraordinaire bon ok merci beaucoup à
la webster maintenant laurent ridel il
nous reste 50 secondes pour répondre à
ça
bon soit question de sylvain rolland est
ce que la seule solution dans le fond ce
n'est pas la décroissance et la
réduction de la consommation
oui la réduction de la consommation isle
à la décroissance des biens matériels
par contre la croissance des
connaissances la croissance des liens de
solidarité
la croissance du partage en général donc
il faut revoir redéfinir notre économie
pour la remettre au service des citoyens
et citoyennes
par respect des limites des écosystèmes
et ça c'est possible
merci très bien très concis merci
beaucoup alors alors là d'autres
questions évidemment wc d'en prendre au
moins trois par pose maintenant que
l'émission recommence donc encore une
fois on vous invite questions
commentaires ou même des idées des
choses que vous faites vous même à votre
domicile pour essayer de mieux respecter
on va dire la planète vous nous écrivez
puis on essaie d'y répondre dans une
vingtaine de minutes lorsqu'on aura
notre prochaine pause publicitaire ici
sur facebook
bonne continuation de cette émission une
émission qui s'appelle ben il est minuit
moins une pour la planète a tout de
suite
le défi économique du 21ème siècle c'est
le défi écologique il faut moins de
croissance fossiles et plus de
croissance durable alors un monde de
ressources finies difficile quand même
de trouver la solution mais le coût
économique du statu quo est plus élevé
que le coût immédiat de l'action pour
stopper la hausse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et même réduire les
émissions
l'économiste britannique nicholas stern
a calculé dans une étude majeure en 2006
que les changements climatiques vont
entraîner à terme une perte sur une
année qui pourrait atteindre de 5 à 20 %
du produit intérieur brut de la planète
alors que les coûts annuels d'une solide
politique de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre serait de 1 % du
pib mondial selon les nations unies les
coûts des catastrophes naturelles ont
presque triplé depuis 20 ans par rapport
aux deux décennies précédentes
l'une des solutions pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est la tarification du carbone qui
n'est pas très populaire mais il faut
comprendre qu ultime mans l'objectif de
la taxe carbone c'est de ne pas la payer
ces de l'éviter l'éviter en changeant un
comportement en faisant un autre choix
plus écologique plus sobre on ne va pas
sortir du capitalisme qui a ses forces
et ses faiblesses mais est il concevable
de laisser le coût économique du
réchauffement climatique aux prochaines
générations à vos enfants vos petits
enfants au nom de notre essor économique
aujourd'hui moyenne gérad viens d'en
parler une des façons de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
la taxation donc imposer une taxe
carbone week est un principe assez
simple finalement c'est de dire que la
personne qui polluent va payer la
pollution que ce jeu coûts soient inclus
dans la transaction
donc j'ai préparé une petite capsule sur
ce concept de la taxe carbone on regarde
ça la tarification sur le carbone est
une taxe environnementale qui vise à
imposer un prix sur les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre son but est d'inciter
les entreprises et les particuliers
à réduire leurs émissions de co2 le prix
du carbone peut être fixée selon
plusieurs modes par exemple une taxe
imposée à l'industrie sur chaque tonne
de co2 émise dans l'atmosphère
ou alors une taxe pour les producteurs
et distributeur de combustibles que les
consommateurs paieront à la pompe ou
encore un système de plafonnement et
d'échangé des émissions comme unis vont
appeler la bourse du carbone au québec
un tel système impose à une centaine
d'entreprises les plus polluantes
un plafond d'émission fixé chaque année
pour ce faire le gouvernement met à
l'encan une quantité limitée de droits
d'émissions sur le marché du carbone les
entreprises peuvent acheter des droits
d'émission si elles polluent au delà du
plafond imposé ou en vendre si elles
font mieux
au canada ses diverses formes de
tarification sont en vigueur dans six
provinces le québec participent à une
bourse du carbone avec la californie
depuis 2014 l'argent perçu est réinvesti
dans le fond vers l'ontario y adhéraient
jusqu'à ce que le gouvernement de
d'oxford s'en retire pour leur part la
colombie britannique et l'alberta impose
toutes les deux des taxes sur le carbone
oui on le voit pas facile pour un
gouvernement de faire consensus lorsque
vient le temps de poser des gestes
concrets et un qui en a fait
l'expérience c'est sans doute nicolas
hulot qui a été ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire en
france jusqu'à sa démission vous en
souvenez peut-être en direct à la radio
c'était l'été dernier je ne veux plus me
mentir je prends la décision de quitter
le gouverneur wesa a été un passage
difficile pour lui au sein du
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron le
célèbre animateur de l'émission ushuaïa
à la télévision une icône vraiment du
mouvement écologiste français lui n'a
pas réussi à imposer un nouveau modèle à
faire changer les choses et il a donc
quitté ses fonctions après dix sept mois
seulement on n'a pas beaucoup entendu
nicolas hulot depuis mais il nous a
reçus il y a quelques jours chez lui à
saint lunaire en bretagne
donc c'est chez vous ici depuis de
nombreuses années quelle année là depuis
presque quinze ans mais j'ai passé toute
mon enfance sur ces bases là c'est vrai
et là comment vous allez quatre mois
après cette démission fracassante à
petit personnel privée familiale
tout va bien j'ai retrouvé un rythme de
vie ma famille après dès que votre
esprit et votre conscience sur l'éveil
pour garder les tables du monde ce qui
se passe en france
le dernier rapport du giec est ce que
votre constat quand même sur l'état de
la planète il est assez honnêtement
chasse est inquiet je suis inquiet parce
que je suis inquiet en même temps je
garde l'espoir garde espoir parce que si
l'intelligence de l'homme voulait bien
se coordonner je pense qu'on peut
résoudre toutes les équations encore
maintenant on a très peu de temps la vie
sur terre tient du miracle
on a envoyé des sondes partout
d'ailleurs dernièrement il y en a une
qualité je crois dans le point le plus
éloigné on n'avait jamais été il n'y a
pas l'ombre d'un but commencement de
preuve de vie est le seul petit endroit
dans cet univers infini où la vie est
plus essais mais c'est sur terre donc on
bénéficie ce miracle mais il tient à
très peu de choses il tient à une petite
pellicule au dessus de la tête qu'on
appelle de l'atmosphère
si on en change la composition qu'on est
en train de le faire il pas sûr que la
vie puisse continuer à s'épanouir et une
petite couche qu'on a sous les pieds pas
ici mais là il s'appelle l'humus et sans
laquelle on peut pas se nourrir
et si chacun avait conscience de ça je
pense qu'on se concernerait tous les
jours devant le miracle
[Musique]
l'homme politique préféré des français
vous n'avez pas réussi à convaincre le
gouvernement de bouger comment on va
faire pour convaincre les gouvernements
qu'il faut affronter sérieusement les
diseurs de la planète
nous n'avions pas la même conscience de
l'importance des changements qu'il
fallait opérer c'est pas le même
diagnostic pas le même gagne au stick je
lui ai dit dans une formule que
peut-être pas très heureuse mais enfin
vous vous mettez pas dans la même
situation
si vous pensez vous avez une branche it
ou si vous avez un cancer mais en face
de métastases et la planète est dans une
situation de cancer très avancé un plan
marshall qu'il faut non là n'est pas là
parce que l'apathie elle est partout et
ouvertement moi je ne veux pas faire
croire qu'avec des moyens limités
on va résoudre des équations aussi
complexe et moi quand je réclame que par
exemple les banques centrales comme
elles l'ont fait en 2008 pour sauver le
système bancaire puisse émettre des
milliers de milliards de dollars ou
d'euros pour investir dans la transition
énergétique parce que ça va nous
épargner des dépenses considérables et
que quand on investit pour la sobriété
énergétique quand on investit pour
produire de l'énergie à partir d'énergie
qui sont gratuites à terme c'est pas des
dépenses inutiles
si on sort pas des sentiers battus alors
qu'on est dans une situation inédite
l'humanité ne s'est jamais trouvé dans
une situation aussi délicate avec des
menaces d'une telle amplitude
si on reste dans les chemins
traditionnels on trompe son monde et moi
je ne voulais pas trompé son monde
n'avait mis en cause les groupes
d'intérêt par exemple vous êtes en
permanence confrontés à des intérêts
particuliers qui additionné ne font ne
font pas évidemment l'intérêt général
donc on parle des pétrolières de
l'industrie agricole
vous avez quand vous êtes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire comme
je l'étais vous êtes à la croisée de
tous les groupes de pression automobile
pétroliers chimiques agricoles que
sais-je encore on entretient une forme
de comment dire de mystification on
pense que l'écologie c'est juste une
corde un changement de cap c'est
vraiment un changement de logiciel c'est
un changement de paradigme
si nous avions 40 ans pour résoudre ce
sujet là je pense qu'on a été très loin
dans l'excès que l'humanité va revenir
une forme de sagesse de sobriété experts
on n'a plus le temps vous vous dites si
on n'a plus le temps on n'a plus le
temps y étant pour beaucoup de tout ça
ça reste lointain quoique dans nos
propres pays et y compris chez nos
voisins aux états unis d'aller en
californie et les conséquences des
changements climatiques c'est plus une
vue de l'esprit
moi quand j'étais ministre je devais
régler des problèmes d'érosion trait de
côte qui était impensable avant c'était
maintenant avec des gens qui sont dans
les habitations sont menacées par le
recul du trait de côte
nous nous avions des inondations à
répétition ce que nous n'avions pas des
extrêmes climatiques voilà nous
commençons à voir des problèmes
maintenant pour adapter l'agriculture à
des changements de température donc les
phénomènes sont même visible à l'oeil nu
y compris chez nous avons évidemment il
fallait aux philippines au sahel pour se
rendre compte ou dans les îles procès
aliens des conséquences du changement
climatique mais les phénomène s'accélère
et médisants à partir de maintenant la
solution elle passe par rouge selon vous
il faut que le citoyen donne un message
implicite clair une sorte d' injonction
politique en disant on nous sommes prêts
voyez en france il ya eu des jours
signer l'initiative s'appelle la sphère
du siècle où en l'espace de quelques
jours plus d'un million 8 de citoyens
ont demandé à l'état dans une action
juridique d'agir conformément aux
objectifs notamment que la france a pris
à la coop 21 au québec on a un pacte de
transition aussi mais il faut que ça me
plaît mais il faut aussi que les gens on
descend dans la rue pour son pouvoir
d'achat et je le comprends mais enfin on
descend très faiblement dans la rue pour
l'avenir de ses enfants est-ce qu'on
descend dans la rue pour sachant que la
tel qu'on est parti en cours de siècles
nos enfants ne pourront plus voir
d'éléphants de lyon à l'état sauvage
probablement dans le monde que la
biodiversité est en train de disparaître
comme le sable dans la main donc faut
aussi que citoyen à un moment ou un
autre
au-delà de ces difficultés immédiates il
s'exprime là il ya eu par exemple hier
en france une pétition où les gens
demandent une journée par semaine où on
ne mange pas de viande n'est pas de
poisson il faut que ce type d'initiative
se multiplient mais alors que du coup de
l'autre côté les politiques se
saisissent de ça et pour vous
personnellement donc l'action maintenant
elle est en dehors des gouvernements je
pense que je dois être résolument du
côté des porteurs de solutions parce que
les solutions existent mais elles
restent l'exception alors qu'elles
doivent devenir la norme comment faire
en sorte de créer une espèce de lobby
des consciences de faire émerger un
lobby des consciences qui exprime ce à
quoi ils sont prêts et qui impose au
gouvernement d'une manière très
pacifique
les 10-15 mesure qui permet
véritablement de rentrer dans une
mutation irréversible et qui soit à la
hauteur des enjeux
il ya probablement un peu d'utopie dans
ce que je suis en train de vous dire je
pense que la seule utopie aujourd'hui
c'est de penser qu'on peut continuer le
modèle existence et que ça va bien se
terminer
ça c'est l'utopie coloniaux merci
beaucoup merci à vous bon retour au
québec merci
[Musique]
oui un homme de conviction quand même
nicolas hulot très déçu par son
expérience au gouvernement parce qu'il
s'est rendu compte qu'on fonce et
toujours l'économie versus l'écologie et
que c'est toujours l'environnement au
fond qui qui perd pas à cause des autres
priorités sont toujours plus urgentes
alors cet appel la mobilisation
citoyenne est d'accord avec ça
absolument je partage tout à fait la
lecture de nicolas hulot et notamment
quand tu dis que la planète est malade
et pique on doit agir de manière urgente
je pense que le foisonnement
d'initiatives citoyennes et citoyens qui
dans leur milieu mais aussi au sein des
entreprises de leur milieu de travail au
sein des gouvernements décident de
passer de la parole aux actes dans
l'urgence je pense que tout ça c'est le
système immunitaire de la terre qui est
en train de s'activer et on le voit
partout à cerdon vu le documentaire
demain ou lu le livre il ya vraiment un
foisonnement partout à travers le québec
et la planète on envoie un extrait ce
soir donc la mobilisation citoyenne elle
est centrale si on veut changer les
choses très concrètement et mettre en
oeuvre ces solutions là parce qu'on le
dit on leur dit les solutions existent
le pack pour la transition vous en avez
fait allusion et en termes de
pourcentage de de signature s'est
absolument pas rabais ce qui s'est fait
en france avec la sphère du sujet les
wii et donc on nous sommes nombreux à
vouloir des changements et maintenant il
faut passer justement à l'action ça fait
plus de 25 ans même plus qu'on en parle
certains alors on ne peut plus le temps
d'attendre parce qu'en fait le constat
on le connaît depuis les années soixante
dix le club de rome
absolument et les gouvernements savaient
y ont commencé à s'engager d'ailleurs
déjà dans les années 80
et même avant alors c'est lui évidemment
qui a mené toute cette bataille pour la
taxe sur l'essence en france avec les
conséquences qu'on a vu pour les légions
mais lui pense que ça passe par la
taxation il faut taxer on parlait de la
taxe sur le carbone alain parce que
lorsqu'il nous parle de dix à quinze
mesures qu'on met en place il y a
inévitablement cette question de la
tarification du carbone
nos très à la mode souvent mais
fondamentale le principe est simple en
quelques secondes si jeune mais aucun
coup sûr cette pollution
je n'ai aucune raison d'investir dans la
réduction des émissions pourquoi je
dépensais pour éviter quelque chose qui
me coûte rien donc j'ai aucune
incitation à innover à mettre en place
des mesures de réduction
je rejette des quantités de polluants
industriels qui vont engendrer des coûts
environnementaux majeurs et s'écoulant
c'est quoi c'est des problèmes de santé
majeurs
db c'est littéralement des incendies des
inondations de l'érosion
on les connaît tous donc pour tenter d
un parti couleurs qui deviennent externe
à la transaction économique qu'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire c'est d'intégrer
six coups dans le coup les biens pour
pouvoir se dire lorsqu'on produit ou
lorsqu'on consomme nous aurons
internaliser ce coût environnemental
intégrés aux roues comme les autres
coûts c'est normal d'intégrer les coûts
de la main d'oeuvre des coûts des
matières premières menace et à répandre
des idées qui contribue à ça c'est
fondamental faut bien sûr respecter bien
sûr cette espèce de transition juste ne
pas accroître les inéquités mais réussir
à faire ça nous permet tout simplement
d'accroire d'innovation de faire une
réduction coup le plus faible possible
et si on ne fait pas ça comme
gouvernement ou si on n'aime pas si on
ne met pas des mesures très strict en
matière de réglementation pour plafonner
ces émissions bah c'est parce qu'on est
un gouvernement climato sceptiques c'est
tout c'est cinq fois c'est un élément
qui est à ce point fondamental on
parlait de stone récemment lorsque il a
publié son étude il ya des phases en
relation cette autant la dernière étude
qu'il a publiés c'est trente anciens
politiciens qui ont réfléchi ces enjeux
et l'approché singles pour y arriver
je dois mettre en place une tarification
du carbone d'au moins 40 dollars la
tonne et en faisant ça le constat est
simple nous ferons des gains collectif
sur la planète et ceux qui vont gagner
de plus seront bien sûr les pays en
développement les plus pauvres c'est
aussi les enjeux d'équité et c'est pour
ça que le secrétaire général des nations
unies nous dit on est dans la bonne voie
mais on va pas assez vite
les changements climatiques sont plus
vite que nous ça presse soyons efficaces
il ya des mesures techniques il ya aussi
des mesures politiques on connaît très
bien la tarification
c'est la première c'est essentiel et
c'est pas normal aujourd'hui que dans un
pays civilisé comme le canada et les
endroits où ça ne coûte rien et
maintenant tonnes de co2 vous aimez mais
quelle ici quand même il ya un consensus
social ce qu'on voit au loin dans
certains lieux où j'écoutais monsieur
hulot qui quelle je crois en a beaucoup
contre les lobbys évidemment au canada
et au québec il ya des lobby très
puissant en mêlée ce qu'on constate au
québec c'est une situation assez
particulière où il ya un consensus
social sur la question de la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
j'étais en pologne en décembre pour la
conférence sur les lits le climat où
j'ai rencontré des gens du conseil du
patronat des gens de la ftq des
syndicats la csn qui disaient tous à la
ministre de l'environnement de l'époque
qui étaient là qui disaient qu'ils nous
n'avions pas il n'est plus là et qui lui
disait arrêté de consulter arrêter de
faire des études
nous allons tous dans la même direction
nous sommes tous d'accord
la situation financière du québec et les
baumes sein du canada aussi donc tous
les éléments sont réunis
ces fonds sont favorables pour qu'il ya
une action beaucoup plus qu'il ya 10 ou
15 ans mais quand même ça n'avance pas
son avance assez assez assez lentement
et c'est étonnant parce que tous les
outils sont là sur la table
en tout cas il ya de plus en plus de
citoyens des jeunes surtout il y en a
ici au québec qui décide de poursuivre
carrément leurs gouvernements pour leur
inaction en matière climatique qui viole
selon eux leur droit fondamental à un
environnement sain
christian là prêt à rencontrer certains
des participants d'une des premières
poursuites de ce genre qui a vu le jour
aux états unis
mais non jacob lebel appelle ses vaches
en ce matin brumeux et frisquet à
roseburg en oregon
ce québécois d'origine vit depuis l'âge
de 4 ans sur la ferme familiale
ses parents ont émigré sur la côte ouest
américaine
ben barka les libelles vivent des
produits de la terre en harmonie avec la
nature
j'ai grandi sur cette ferme avec
certaines valeurs un cuir la valeur
simple de protéger notre environnement
le réchauffement du climat menace leur
mode de vie
la saison de feu a augmenté d'à peu près
21 jours dans les années 1970 à au
dessus de 116 jours maintenant
jacob est un des 21 jeunes américains
qui poursuivent en justice le
gouvernement des états unis
il dénonce l'inaction des élus et les
meilleurs scientifiques ils ont toutes
les ressources pour trouver des
solutions
je peux pas croire que qui peuvent pas
prendre des actions pour arrêter de nous
mettre en danger
quel psy giuliana est un autre des
visages de cette poursuite contre l'état
le plus puissant de la planète
la cause porte d'ailleurs son nom
giuliana contre le gouvernement
américain l'administration de chambre se
défend bec et ongle cassé en a assez de
la négligence environnementale de ses
aînés
[Musique]
l'avocate des jeunes accusent l'état de
tenir deux discours un an public et
l'autre devant les juges le chercheur
hugo séguin fait son doctorat en éthique
environnementale à l'université de
l'oregon
ils appuient la cause des jeunes c'est
qu'elle donne un point d'entrée à toute
une génération pour saisir nos lancers
c'est ma cause
à moi et vous avez vous mal est vrai pas
mon ami de l'autre côté du pays en
floride
li vaille 11 ans est le plus jeune des
requins de cette poursuite
l'île de sainte-thérèse beach tout près
de cap canaveral et son terrain de jeu
il est inquiet pour sa plage et les
espèces qui y vivent une algue toxique a
provoqué une marée rouge dans ce coin de
la floride dans les derniers mois
un désastre dû entre autres aux
fertilisants et à la hausse des
températures dans l'atlantique il
ce qui vient aussi l'action de ces
jeunes est nécessaire affirme hugo
séguin
mais le temps presse
d'ici 2050 la nos économies ici dans les
grands pays industrialisés devront tête
à toutes fins pratiques décarboniser
alors ça veut dire qu'il reste plus
beaucoup de temps
si on veut être à la hauteur de l'enjeu
il n'est jamais trop tard a répliqué
c'est julian à quatorze juges
affirme-t-elle ont déjà rejeté les
arguments des avocats du gouvernement
américain marc jacobs lebel espère
encore vivre longtemps en oregon malgré
la menace des feux nous sommes tous dit
il
dans cette course contre la montre tu
peux être un étudiant qui peut être un
écrivain est un artiste un fermier un
ingénieur il a des manières de créer un
meilleur monde pour nous tous le peut-il
y vas y fais du réchauffement climatique
un combat de tous les jours une bataille
qu'il veut gagner pour sauver la planète
mais aussi sont ils
cette cause et surtout celle de ces
jeunes qui doivent maintenant réparer
les dégâts laissés par leurs années il
n'est peut-être pas trop tard mais leur
avenir portera toujours les traces des
négligences du passé
[Musique]
11 ans seulement ce jeune quand même
mais lors vous vous êtes justement
conseillère pour des jeunes qui
poursuivent le gouvernement du canada le
même genre de cause qu'est ce qui les
motive qu'est ce qu'ils disent leurs
droits un environnement c'est leur droit
un avenir où ils auront une qualité de
vie comparable à la nôtre parce que
c'est ça qui est menacée et on le voit
très clairement qu'on regarde les
engagements du gouvernement fédéral
depuis les les dernières années en fait
déjà en 1988 le gouvernement fédéral
avait réalisé l'urgence d'agir pour les
changements climatiques ils se sont
donné des cibles des cibles qui n'ont
jamais été atteinte en plus d'être
insuffisante
quand on la compare à l'état de la
science des connaissances actuelles donc
les jeunes de moins de 35 ans dans ce
cas-ci since i ne demandait d'action
collective qui est porté par
environnement jeunesse qui regroupe qui
va représenter en fait tous les jeunes
de moins de prendre cinq ans mais
quelles sont les chances justement que
ça aboutisse c'est que cette justice
climatique là maintenant on se parle en
fait si on regarde les droits qui sont
protégés par la charte dont ledroit
laquelle que l'environnement le droit à
la santé à la sécurité
même le droit à la vie à la limite quand
on regarde ce qui s'en vient c'est des
droits qui doivent être protégés par les
tribunaux donc c'est les gouvernements
ne protège pas ses droits le les
gouverneurs et les tribunaux ont la
responsabilité de faire en sorte que les
gouvernements le fasse et vous savez ces
procédures là on court un petit peu
partout à travers la planète
on ne parle des etats-unis aux pays-bas
les gouvernements ont les tribunaux par
dont on reconnaît sans forcer les
gouvernements à agir et aussi non
seulement à faa'a à prendre des mesures
mais à à améliorer la qualité des cibles
qu'il sait qu'il s'adonne il ya un droit
qui est en train de se développer peu
partout à travers le monde surtout en
europe mais on voit c'est sûr que c'est
le fameux droit des générations futures
autrement dit que ces générations ont
droit à un avenir sain et le droit des
générations futures moi je fais le pari
que des avocats
d'ici cinq dix quinze ans qu'ils vont
développer ça tranquillement et ils
rendent sur beaucoup plus concret
et beaucoup plus difficile pour les
gouvernements alors on va suivre toutes
ces causes maintenant il y en a qui
poursuivent donc y en a d'autres qui se
mobilisent pour agir localement sans
attente vraiment les gouvernements voici
l'exemple de citoyenne la mrc de
maskinongé en mauricie rappelle karine
anglaise et contribue à la
carboneutralité la mrc maskinongé
le projet en route vers la
carboneutralité a vraiment émergé d'un
besoin collectif dans les discussions
les changements climatiques étaient
souvent au coeur des différents échanges
merci de participer au premier rendez
vous car bon ordre de la mrc de
maskinongé
les participants qui sont présents au
rendez vous car bonheur sont des membres
des comités soit du secteur agricole de
l'entreprise milieu municipal ou encore
des citoyens peu importe où ils sont
rendus dans leur prise de conscience de
l'importance de s'impliquer dans la
lutte aux changements climatiques
pouvait embarquer dans le projet et le
faire vraiment à leur savoir et à la
réalité
muller l'émission des gaz à effet de
serre sur notre territoire
la grande source de toute évidence le
transport le territoire est très vaste
et très grand beaucoup de route c'est
une réalité qu'on a sur notre territoire
mais est pas inconnu en perthois parce
que le québec évidemment le fait d'être
car bonheur et une vision
ça permet aux gens de réaliser
concrètement qu'ils ont un pouvoir et
d'action et d'influencé aussi sur les
autres
les gens qui se sentent pas concernés
aujourd'hui convoi qui se passe quelque
chose qu'ils vont avoir envie l'heure
d'embarquer lada par fierté puis par
envie aussi de faire les choses de
manière interne alors d'autres questions
on parle depuis le début beaucoup de
transport collectif transport en commun
et on a beaucoup de questions là dessus
parce que par exemple johanne mercier et
ariane bélanger nous disent mais c'est
bien beau dans des villes comme montréal
et di linh rose ya toutes sortes de
projets mais en région dans milieu d'un
milieu rural qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
lancer une question qui nous revient
souvent ce soir justement avec catherine
morency qu'est ce qu'on fait en régions
lorsqu'on n'est pas desservie par ce
type de transport qu'on peut retrouver
dans les grands centres urbains
oui comme je l'aï dit cela développe des
nouvelles technologies téléphones et
toutes les technologies informationnel
permettent net mart d'imaginer des
routes de transport en commun avec des
petits véhicules qui vont être opérés au
besoin parce qu'en fait le dfid
opérations de transport en commun de
type classique c'est quand la population
et dispersés et que la demande est
faible ça coûte trop cher c'est pas
efficaces et plus sûrs pas suffisamment
d'alliés dans le bus
donc il faut combiner des services de
véhicules partagés quelqu'un besoin d'un
véhicule pour aller faire les courses au
lieu de l'avoir poussé d'équerré
stationnés mais je le fais du temps pour
qu'il puisse emprunter pour une période
de temps danse et des systèmes de
véhicules partagés qu'on met en place
mais d'avoir des systèmes de vélopartage
aussi pour faciliter le recours aux
modes actifs
bientôt on peut y être par exemple un
projet pilote à saint bruno
comment on épand c'est une ville qui est
moins dense mais c'est des services de
microsoft a dit que les gens m'ont dit
moi j'ai besoin de me déplacer pour
aller à tel endroit et il ya des
chroniques petit coupé des routes qui
vont se créer
adrien véhicule par exemple de 5 ou 7
places qui va faire une route pour
recueillir deux ou trois passages et
peut-être sept et qui va les amener à
destination souvent l'enjeu c'est
vraiment de faire en sorte que les gens
n'aient pas toujours et recourir aux
véhicules pour des déplacements
réguliers
comment on fait pour convaincre les
pouvoirs publics d'investir dans plus de
transports en publics ne en commun
justement dans les régions un peu plus
éloigné
c'est un enjeu économique sur la
question des coûts de transport posséder
véhicule ça coûte quand même cher et on
n'utilise pas tant que ça bien même des
services on a vu dans des certains
quartiers des gens qui ont décidé de
mettre en commun leurs véhicules ça se
mange un véhicule jeu
indisponible pour certaines plages
horaires comme ça quelqu'un d'autre pour
utiliser donc a vraiment cette idée de
mettre en commun des véhicules que ce
soit par le biais de particuliers ou par
le biais des municipalités par le biais
de compagnies privées et de faire en
sorte que c'est quelqu'un puisse se
déplacer au niveau du transport en
commun
on n'a pas le choix c'est dans la
politique nationale offrir 4 alternative
de mobilité durable à 70% des risques
des résidents du québec ça ça veut dire
70% que c'est tous les résultats des
régions métropolitaines héros
métropolitaine en a pas juste le plateau
mont royal
c'est beaucoup de gens vraiment
évidemment dans les territoires ruraux
c'est un autre enjeu
il faut travailler à la marche la marche
aussi partout des déplacements courts
faut travailler au vélo parce que le
vélo peut couvrir jusqu'à 5 km il est
électrique on peut aller encore plus
loin
faut vraiment envisager tous les
territoires en imaginant qui pourrait y
avoir d'autres modes utilisé il pensait
des offres alternatives de transport en
commun
c'est une paire mais on est frileux au
québec dans ses investissements en
transport en commun malgré tout et gains
à long terme
on se questionne encore serait ce qu on
fait un très mauvais à québec ça semble
un élément compliqué à régler
alors qu'est-ce qu'on compense qui se
passe en france on a deux nombres abl
petite municipalité de la paille de
sherbrooke drummondville qui ont des
traits - ou des métros donc on a fait le
choix d'investir collectivement et de
créer ces infrastructures publiques
autour de ces bacs de ses
infrastructures de transport en commun
ce qu'on ne fait à peu près pas au
québec en dehors de montréal et bientôt
québec
ça permet à tout le monde se déplacer je
vous laisse parce qu'évidemment
l'émission se poursuit ici en direct
dans cinq secondes donc d'autres
questions d'autres commentaires on y
réponde et qu'on peut dans la prochaine
pause
merci de nous suivre ce soir sur
facebook live ici au québec et partout
dans l'ue en 2050 près de 10 milliards
d'humains sur la terre et jusqu'à preuve
du contraire nous aurons tous besoin de
manger
mais il faudra peut-être revoir vos
habitudes alimentaires parce que déjà
elle épuise la planète dans les océans
90 % des poissons sont exploitées au
maximum ou carrément surexploitées
autrement dit on les mange plus vite
qu'il n'arrive à se reproduire et du
côté de l'agriculture on se met aussi à
des ressources qui ne sont pas
inépuisables
les trois quarts de toutes les terres
agricoles du monde sont accaparés par le
bétail
ce sont soit des pâturages soit des
terres où l'on fait pousser de la
nourriture pour le bétail
mais ce n'est pas la manière la plus
efficace de nourrir la planète
même si l eau que beaucoup d espace la
production de viandes et produits
laitiers ne fournit que 17 % de l'apport
calorique mondiale beaucoup de
territoires et dont utilisé entre autres
pour peu de calories au final alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait on peut manger
moins de viande et mettre fin au
gaspillage alimentaire parce que même
acheté en solde
la nourriture est trop précieuse pour
philippe katerine viennent en parler le
gaspillage alimentaire est un réel enjeu
environnemental et sébastien a lancé un
des secteurs aussi sur lequel on peut
agir parce que c'est assez proche de
nous c'est notre frigidaire c'est notre
assiette
ouais c'est plutôt simple et ça paraît
bête mais éliminer le gaspillage
alimentaire ça ferait une différence
monumental voyez pourquoi en quelques
chiffres d'abord savez-vous quelle
proportion de la nourriture produite
dans le monde chaque année termine au
dépotoir le tiers + 30 % des aliments
sont soient perdus soit jetée et ça
représente un milliard trois cents
millions de tonnes de nourriture
bien sûr ça a un impact économique il
est évaluée à 17 milliards de dollars
par année au canada seulement
ça c'est plus de 1000 $ par ménage par
année quand même et on est pas qu
environnemental bien sûr en fait on
évalue que si le gaspillage alimentaire
et
est un pays il serait le troisième plus
grand émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
dans le monde après la chine et les
états unis
alors de quoi donner le vertige vraiment
est ce parce qu'on gaspé de l'eau des
terres agricoles il ya du transport
inutile dans ses pertes des pertes qui
se font surtout à la maison alors
quelques exemples extrapolé mais pour
vous donner une idée de l'impact de vos
déchets de table alors une baguette
jeter c'est à peu près l'équivalent de
cent bouteilles d'eau de plastique qu'on
met à la poubelle alors qu'un steak
jeter c'est l'équivalent de rouler
environ 5 km en voiture donc parmi les
solutions elles vont vous sembler simple
c'est peut-être parce qu'elles le sont
mais mieux planifier ses repas congelés
reste réutiliser les aliments qui sont
trop mûres une tiers des aliments qui
sont jetés 6 1 c'est incroyable quand
même ça oui c'est vrai ça donne le
vertige
merci s'est passé en croit donc on
produit énormément de déchet aussi le
canada est d'ailleurs le plus gros
producteurs de déchets des pays de le
céder juste pour vous donner une idée
chaque québécois produit en moyenne 187
kg de déchets organiques par an c'est
beaucoup
idéalement il faut donc réduire ses
déchets et revaloriser aussi ce qui
reste comme on a essayé de le faire à
cacouna dans le bas saint laurent où
s'est rendue frédéric arnault
[Musique]
dans un des paysages bucoliques du bas
du fleuve à cacouna
il y as et goélands recherche de
matières organiques contenues dans ce
dépotoir et à quelques dizaines de
mètres de là cette curieuse usine c'est
une fierté parce que j'ai quand même
consacré plusieurs années de ma vie à ce
projet lors cette usine c'est un peu le
bb de serge forest construite au coût de
26 millions de dollars en 2015
elle est unique en son genre en plus de
traiter le biogaz qu'on produit par
biométhanisation
on traite aussi le méthane qui se dégage
du lieu d'enfouissement technique donc
le dépotoir
alors la biométhanisation comment ça
marche tout commence ici avec cette
collecte de déchets organiques
les fameux déchets de table que les
résidents mettre dans leur fameux bac
tort
rendez-vous maintenant à l' usine pour
transformer tout ça en biogaz
pour nourrir cette usine il faut des
matières organiques qui vont être broyés
par une mâchoire géante
une fois bien broyer il faut préparer la
digestion de cette matière il faut donc
de la salive et dans ce cas ci c'est
dans le milieu acide de l'hydrolyse
heures que ça se passe la mixture est
chauffée à 55 degrés est est ensuite
transféré dans cette estomac gigantesque
le digesteur essai de c'est estomac que
va sortir le fameux biogaz il reste
alors deux étapes finales purifier le
gaz et ensuite lui rendre liquide en le
refroidissant à moins 160 degrés pour
pouvoir le transporter premier avantage
c'est qu'on détourne la matière
organique de l'enfouissement
ensuite on produit un carburant qui vont
remplacer un carburant de sources
fossiles et ont produit un fertilisant
valorisant milliards
ce fertilisant qu'on appelle le digestat
permet aux agriculteurs d'enrichir leur
sol bref un retour à la nature
j'ai de la misère à comprendre qu'on
continue à enfler de la matière
organique
c'est une ressource naturelle dans la
région seulement une personne sur trois
remplissons bacs bruns
pas assez de matière première pour
produire de grandes quantités de biogaz
depuis trois ans et demi l'usiné a
produit plus d'un million de mètres
cubes de biogaz
mais il est brûlé dans cette torchère
car après bien des tests pour purifier
et liquéfier le gaz ainsi que des bris
technique
le biogaz n'est toujours pas utilisable
comme carburant certain que les gens se
questionnent puis avec raison aussi
après après trois ans le monde se
demande mais si je ferais y croit
beaucoup
je suis originaire d et la madeleine il
y avait un temps on a senti l'urgence
d'installer la cueillette des matières
organiques
certains m'ont dit oui c'est un millier
celui-là mais il reste que n'importe où
connaissent une grosse cata c'est quand
même une île une grosse partie terre qui
sont peut-être grande planète le
meilleur indice d'un succès futur pour
lui se trouve quelque part dans ce
dépotoir
car le jour où il y aura presque plus de
goélands il aura réussi une partie de sa
mission
malheureusement on n'arrive pas encore à
produire du carburant dans ce cas là
mais ça se fait ailleurs quand même hein
ça marche
effectivement ce qu'on essaie de faire
littéralement cette approche c'est de
créer un nouveau secteur énergétique un
nouveau secteur économique on un modèle
économique
lignières assez simple on prend des
ressources on les transforme dans nos
usines en biens et en services
ensuite on les consomme et une fois
qu'on a fait ça on les rejette on les
oublie ça n'existe plus mais on sait
aujourd'hui que la pas de sens parce que
ces rejets reste quelque part je sois
une tonne de co2 la matière organique ou
des plastiques
qu'importe qu'on rejette ce alors un
impact sur cet environnement
donc ce qu'il faut maintenant réussir à
faire c'est intégrer sa matière visuelle
dans ce circuit économique faire
littéralement ce qu'on appelle une
économie circulaire pour encore une fois
réduire cet impact environnemental et
par le domaine circulaire c'est qu'on
produit quelque chose et on le ramène
comme un temps où les d'avoir un déchet
simplement on le ramène comme étant
nouvelles ressources utilisables par
quelqu'un d'autre
donc soit une entreprise qui va utiliser
un résidu pour faire un nouveau bien ou
encore une fois un déchet qu'on ne
transforme et parce que leur énergie ou
en engrais
donc on essaie de fermer cette boucle à
pour éviter de perdre si les ressources
l'on parle ici de déchets urbains
mais c'est la même chose pour les
résoudre agricole les déchets forestiers
cessa inventer une nouvelle économie
faire un lien entre réduction des gaz à
effet de serre et gains économiques
création d'emplois on entendu quelqu'un
ne fallait pas longtemps et ça me permet
donc de créer de la richesse en créant
de nouveaux biens et durant l'écriture
ça passe par nos déchets exactement en
partie ce n'est pas que ça mais c'est
faisable ça se fait beaucoup en europe
ici qu'est ce qu'on fait beaucoup de
recherches on met en place des plans
pilotes on en a fait plusieurs on
commence à mettre des structures
industrielles
ça fonctionne pas très bien pour
l'instant mais on fait beaucoup ça en
estrie en montérégie en mauricie sont la
côte nord enerkem face à edmonton donc
on essaie de travailler sur un ensemble
de deux nouveaux modèles économiques
mais pour y arriver c'est compliqué au
niveau technique sur le 100 ma collègue
mais en même temps il faut encore
l'aspect hygiénique travail sur le
premier exactement mais ça fonctionne
ailleurs donc il faut l'adapter aux
types de déchets à leur méditer à
comment on réussit à travail
adéquatement il faut acquérir cette
connaissance aussi et gérer ses
ressources littéralement au niveau des
matières isolé d'éclatement parce que
bientôt on va se dire qui et où
j'utilise ces ressources de matières
organiques ces déchets urbains pour
faire de l'énergie
mais pour y arriver il faut aussi un
cadre institutionnel adéquat il faut
peut-être se dire on va payer plus cher
ce gaz naturel quand gaz qui émet des
gaz à effet de serre normalement donc
ces biocarburants devront être valorisé
il faut inciter les entreprises à faire
ce virage à faire plus de recherche plus
d'innovation parce que pour l'instant ça
coûte très très cher et il ya peu de
gains à développer ces niveaux carburant
à coûts plus élevés et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut revoir aussi ce cadre
économique pour mettre en place des
structures de financement et une
tarification différente mais quand même
quand on voit tous ces clichés tout ce
gaspillage donc faut quand même réduire
à la source ou s'il a absolument c'est
la première chose à faire on parle la
hiérarchie des 3 hervé
réduisez réutilisez recyclez valorisant
quand même mais mais réduire c'est tout
simple on voit tout le mouvement zéro
déchet qui est très fort en ce moment au
québec
il vient de san et s'implique aussi de
concevoir nos emballages autrement
concevoir nos produits autrement pour
qu'il dure plus longtemps
on est beaucoup dans ce qu'on appelle
l'obsolescence programmée ça dure des
billets qui ont une courte durée de vie
rappelez vous il ya pas si longtemps que
ça quand une laveuse hongrie paix et est
et tabriz et la plupart du temps le
réparer et trop souvent maintenant on
nous dit c'est pas réparable ça va
coûter moins cher sa venue à la fête
19 et ça c'est notamment parce que le
prix environnemental tout le bien qu'on
pense de l'extraction des ressources
entre les conséquences que ça ce que ça
va nous coûter en termes de changement
qui met ces pollutions de l'eau et coup
sur la santé n'est pas comptabilisé dans
les grille pain qui se vend à 25 dollars
ou et la laveuse heures donc sa demande
de faire d'éco-conception qui permet une
réduction à la source qui facilite leur
esclave mais un des moyens qu'on a
trouvée pour gérer peut-être plus
efficacement tous ses déchets c'est le
recyclage tous les pays cependant ne
sont pas au même point en russie par
exemple dans la capitale moscou ont
produit plus de 25 millions de tonnes de
déchets par année
il ya seulement 10 % qui sont recyclées
nous raconte tamar altéré sco
imaginez une ville de plus de 12
millions d'habitants une population qui
consomme arrête m'affole une mégapole où
il n'existe pourtant aucun programme de
recyclage officiel quelques petits
centres de tri mais encore doit-on les
trouver il faut être drôlement motivé
pour recycler ses ordures à moscou et
tous les moyens sont bons pour convertir
le moscow dit ce matin l'om j'espère
écologique offre des billets gratuits
pour le théâtre et le viser en échange
des ordures ménagères privilège que moi
je n'embaucherai jean là au moins on a
fait ça pour attirer l'attention des
citoyens pour que la planète ne soit
plus la grande poubelle qu'elle est
devenue tradition série lost j'ai pris
la décision de filtrer mes déchets parce
que mes beaux parents habitent juste à
côté denis des montagnes d'ordures et
chaque fois que j'y passe ça me fait
peur
c'est en effet une véritable catastrophe
écologique qui se déroule dans la caisse
ni indifférence du gouvernement russe
c'est montagne artificielle sont des
ordures accumulées et elles sont
devenues la norme en banlieue de la
capitale
en l'absence de réglementation ce qui
fait m'organise x était qu'à part et
l'industrie il aura fallu en arriver là
des odeurs putrides et même des
intoxications pour que les citoyens
sortent dans la rue
désespérée pour demander au gouvernement
de trouver une solution
aujourd'hui ceux qui recyclent le font
grâce au bouche à oreille a vendu son
ministère une histoire celio igor est
membre d'une petite armée de bénévoles
avec sa camionnette il arpente les
quartiers résidentiels
alors on est dans l'est de moscou igor
atteint cliente qui lui a signifié par
internet qu'elle allait venir déposer du
recyclage et toute la journée ils
passent au travers des laisses un rythme
assez effréné et tout ça comme bénévole
il suffit de le suivre quelques heures
pour constater à quel point les russes
n'y connaissent rien malgré toute la
bonne volonté
google
ap
bon ce ne sont pas moins d'un an
j'espère a été notre mot cerner audio de
l'état participerait plus au recyclage
alors moi je le fais pour avoir la
conscience marquer sa récolte et
acheminé ici l usine plast ressources à
100 km 2 me l'homme d'affaires guy
bogoliubov s'est lancé dans la gestion
des déchets ya trois ans à ses risques
et périls shaqiri tu ne touches tôt
ronan restreignait ce qui m'a choqué
c'est qu'il n'y avait aucune
organisation tout était contrôlé par la
mafia il n'y avait pas une seule règle
et aucun organisme officiel
ici on recycle tous les types de déchets
plastiques ces revenus provient
exclusivement des matières traitées qui
sont ensuite revendus qui était au
départ une opportunité d'affaires et de
vocations j'ai rencontré des écologistes
j'ai commencé à participer à des
séminaires
si les affaires vont bien et evgeny
s'inquiète du sort des petites
compagnies verte comme la sienne alors
que le gouvernement russe s'apprête à
s'approprier la gestion des déchets
traités le coach autre chose qu il ya un
proverbe russe qui dit on a voulu faire
pour le mieux mais on a fait comme
d'habitude c'est exactement ce qui
arrive avec le dossier des déchets
car le gouvernement prévoit désormais
construire 5 incinérateur géant
moscou deux bras à temps pour son
programme de recyclage
alors on le voit tous les pays n'en sont
pas au même point parce qu'ici quand
même on recycle depuis longtemps même si
on l'éprouvent certaines difficultés en
ce moment notre recyclage mais c'est une
solution de transition dans le recyclage
c'est pas une fin en soi mais en fait
quand on voit des reportages comme ça on
se dit quelque chose très ambivalents et
d'absurde dans cette logique de
recyclage et quand le consommateur
achète il va prendre un produit avec
tout ce qui vient avec
ils vont avoir un passage très éphémère
entre ses mains mais il va s'en vont on
envoyer à leurs biens à l'autre bout de
tout un défi logistique de transport
donc produire le produit l'amener
jusqu'au consommateur
il faut imaginer que si dans nos
véhicules on a dû être transporté ce
qu'on transporte dans les camions c'est
des emballages principalement au
transport des emballages et du vivre
différemment et là on amène sont
consommables ont parce que ça la fin il
faut aussi gérer les enjeux logistique
de transport de ces matériaux est
vraiment quelque chose d'absurde
je comprends que il ya un marché
associée au recyclage des produits on
pourrait jusqu'à 8 août à los que mais
en même temps mais ce que je dis c'est
que oui il faut on a créé le problème il
existe on a des choses à recycler faut
s'en occuper mais en même temps il faut
aussi se reculer dans la chaîne et dire
il faut réduire l'innovation devrait la
mettre sur la façon dont on développe
ses produits
et qu'est ce qu'on a fait aux
consommateurs parce que je ne passe que
plusieurs consommateurs qui sont un peu
exaspéré qu'on peut acheter ici parce
qu'on n'a pas l'offre
là je pense qu'il ya un travail très
très important du gouvernement à faire
en sorte que les offres soient plus
disponibles et jean vallée choisi ne
s'est pas disponible donc ayant un
travail de réglementation de taxation de
même d'interdiction il faut réglementer
on a des endroits ils vont interdire le
plastique à usage unique qui est
vraiment quelque chose tu nous laisses
tellement éphémère le fou c'est fini et
on le jette mais c'est tout tout ce qui
est bien impliqué pour la production
transport un vaisseau consommateur sait
c'est vraiment absurde absurde
mais qu'est-ce qui est comment on peut
faire pour repos pour avoir moins de
déchets au fond pour consommer moins moi
ya les choix individuels mais je pense
apprend aussi des choix collectifs ça
prend des lois contre le gaspillage
notamment contre le gaspillage
alimentaire on le vit en europe et ça a
donné lieu à beaucoup plus de dons
alimentaires vers les banques une
meilleure gestion des débats des
aliments loi contre l'obsolescence
programmée aussi le aussi on voit des
changements obligé par exemple on pense
à toute l'industrie du numérique
tous les appareils qui doivent être
changées rapidement qu'ils peuvent pas
être réparés dirigeants pour que ça
change qui à court terme oui nous on
peut essayer d'acheter le moins le moins
emballé possible et faire des demandes à
à nous commerçants mais il faut un
moment donné mettre en place des choix
collectifs
il ya des entreprises qui font des
champs choses très intéressantes en
restant par exemple propriétaire des
biais plutôt et donc de vendre un
service plutôt qu'un produit on le voit
dans les photocopieurs xerox par exemple
les gens plutôt que d'acheter les
photocopieurs les entreprises souvent
vont payer le nombre de pages qui vont
être utilisés et ça ça s est les
propriétaires des photocopieurs à faire
des appareils de meilleure qualité que
vont pouvoir à ce moment leur réparer
plus facilement donc ses dessins stif
comme ceux qui changent notre rapport
aux objets ou matériel sans qu'on est
toujours 2e en est les propriétaires en
occident c'est drôle on dirait qu'on est
cette année non il ya eu une crise dans
le recyclage pas justice y en aura
poussé parce que nous en envoyer tous
les produits de recyclage en asie et là
les choses sont évidemment d'échelon
dire on n'en veut plus de votes
recyclage c'est pas du bon matériau pour
nous on peut peut rien faire avec ça et
par notre sous de ces années c'est comme
si on s'était donné bonne conscience
dans le fond en recyclant toutes nos
choses en envoyant nos déchets
électroniques justement en inde au
bangladesh en afrique et là soudainement
cette cause et réclamé dans cette
arnaque
alors peut-être que cette crise va
mettre faire donner naissance à des
solutions plus innovantes et peut-être
aussi inciter les gens à consommer moins
consommer mieux avec des produits de
meilleure qualité et les entreprises
comme disait lors à changer leurs
pratiques et à nous offrir des produits
réparable oui donc on l'évoquait parce
que on parlait du suremballage encore
des produits à usage unique que l'union
européenne d'ailleurs vient d'interdire
comme les pailles ou les verres de
plastique et là dessus le canada est
quand même assez tout ça se retrouve
bien souvent dans la nature vous
souvenez sûrement de ces images vraiment
terrible de continent de plastique qui
jonchent les océans
d'un point de vue très local raphaël
bouvier auclair montre maintenant
comment la ville de baltimore a mis au
point un système assez ingénieux vous
allez voir pour collecter les déchets
qui jonchent son port bon témoin une
ville mal aimé qui depuis des années
tente de se refaire une beauté
c'est un port magnifique mais la
première chose que les gens voient sont
les déchets et il trouve le port
dégoûtant john gadret a souvent entendu
les touristes se plaindre de la présence
de déchets dans le port de bales témoins
en collaboration avec la ville et
différents organismes
l'ingénieur a donc créé cette machine on
l'appelle mister trashouille alimentée
par le courant d'eau et par l'énergie
solaire
mes sculptures achoui aurait recueilli
les déchets de la ville qui se
retrouvent dans l'eau si ces déchets
n'étaient pas ramassé il finirait dans
la baie de chesapeake et ensuite dans
l'océan atlantique mégots de cigarettes
bouteilles sacs de plastique contenant
de styromousse
on y retrouve de temps et parfois
quelques surprises un kayak une guitare
et même un python s'ils sont faufilés
mais essentiellement ce sont des ordures
cavale cette machine et mr trash ou et
on a bon appétit
depuis 2014 mail tonnes de déchets ont
été recueillis ah bon témoin cette
machine est beaucoup plus qu'un outil
pour combattre la pollution par le
plastique
elle est en fait devenue une véritable
mascotte de la ville et de son port les
gens se souviennent d'une chose le jour
où on en récupère un certain alors quand
on a décidé de créer une bière annales
on s'est dit qu'il fallait l'a nommé
après le pit ont perdu adam lind quest a
contribué à créer ce personnage c'est
lui qui a pensé à ajouter des yeux à la
machine chandail bière peluche
il ya même un festival est une chanson
qui rendent hommage à mr achoui à
[Musique]
déjà la quantité impressionnante de
déchets amassés par mr trash où il a
poussé la ville à interdire
l'utilisation de contenants styromousse
dans les restaurants le genre de
décision qui permettra peut-être un jour
à mr tu as choisi de prendre sa retraite
[Musique]
le 30 décembre 2016 j'ai promis 17 pieds
de terrain juste d'un coup depuis 1981
je porte du 75 pieds de terrain en
vivant alors de retour sur le plateau
les questions continuent d'affluer
devant vous en remercie énormément mais
c'est vrai qu'on prend beaucoup d
initiatives citoyennes qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire la maison mais les grandes
entreprises telles que font-elles
exactement on va en parler avec alain
webster donc collé une question monsieur
webster avec une question qui est posée
par julie lussier est ce que davantage
de réglementation ou des lois plus
sévères devraient ou pourraient être
imposées aux entreprises qui ont un
impact négatif sur l'environnement
évidemment mais ces réglementations
comme ça faire de différentes façons
c'est soit une contrainte légale qui dit
tu es obligé de faire quelque chose tu
limiter ses émissions à s'entendre mais
l'autre façon de mettre en place un
cadre réglementaire 1 intervention de
l'état c'est de t'imposer un coût
financier met en place une taxe ou
mettent en place qu'on ait faite au
québec un système de permis échangeables
qui va obliger à plafonner des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre éventuellement
semer le coup c'est eux dépassent ce
plafond
donc l'idée c'est de se dire que le
gouvernement doit intervenir pour
corriger ce qu'on appelle en économie
c'est défaillante du marché certains
capacité du marché d'intégrer par
lui-même ses coût environnemental dont
vous avez tout à fait raison il faut
absolument que l'état intervienne il
peut le faire de façon réglementaire
mais généralement lorsqu'on impose un
cadre fixe c'est comme s'ils ont des
entreprises store une seule façon de ti
conformer quand on utilise des
instruments économiques pour y arriver
on laisse une marge de manoeuvre plus
grande pour dire trouve la solution est
trouvée là au coût le plus bas possible
ça permettra pour la mine dépenses d'en
faire plus en matière environnementale
ou pour un maigre gain environnemental
dépenses et collectivement moins pour
cet enjeu qui font intervenir
reste à savoir comment et l'idée c'est
de définir les meilleures stratégies
gouvernementales me oui si on appelle ça
le principe pollueur payeur c'est
d'amener cette entreprise a semé le
courriel mais on a la pression puis
c'est des commentaires qui reviennent
beaucoup ce soir dans ce convoi son
facebook c'est que on a l'impression que
les gouvernements ils sont frileux par
rapport à ça ils veulent pas trop faire
peur aux entreprises parce qu'après tout
ils investissent et sait donc comment on
fait pour sortir de ce carcan là parce
qu'on ne prend pas en compte ces coups
qu'on appelle externe s'écoute cette
pollution si on prend que les coûts des
changements climatiques
ce coût social du carbone il était venu
en europe à au moins 30 euros donc
environ 50 dollars la tonne ont concédé
aujourd'hui l'entreprise qui émet des
gaz à effet de serre
lorsque je ne lui impose aucun frais
comme en ontario ça signifie que
j'accepte qu'elle émet une tonne de co2
et qu'elle va causer 70 là pour 50
dollars au moins de dommages
quelque part sur la planète mais on va
dégrader donc cette économie globale ce
bien commun pour une somme élevée c'est
pas conformes à notre modèle économique
n'est pas conforme au marché donc aider
c'est de se servir de ces mécanismes de
marché pour l'instant on n'arrive pas à
intégrer l'environnement tout seul on va
forcer donc cette intégration
mais on est frileux de le faire pourquoi
peut-être parce que les gens ne voient
pas vraiment les conséquences
de ses impacts que ce disent les les
plastiques les enfui je les vois pas les
matières résiduelles j'ai l'impression
que ça pas vraiment d'impact chez moi
les changements climatiques ne même
pacte auront pas et là qu'est ce qu'on
observe depuis quelques décennies
les gens se disent ah non j'ai les
conséquences matières résiduelles
sélective iasi en train de contaminer
bon sol mon nom les changements
climatiques ont des impacts en matière
d'inondations en tête cette forêt et
tout à coup on réalise qu'on dit depuis
des années sa date de pigments 1920
assiette il ya des coûts externes et
s'écoule à quelqu'un quelque part pour
l'assumer
l'idée ce serait à l'entreprise au
départ et semble un peu de misère à le
faire mais je pense qu'on aura de moins
en moins de difficultés parce que les
gens sont justement de plus en plus
conscientisés encaissés bon je vous
laisse d'autres questions dans la
prochaine pause et on va dire vous
présentez daniel dominique paquin qui
fait partie du réseau
après l'émission on va continuer à
prendre d'autres questions et vos
commentaires on aura quinze minutes de
plus que l'émission ici qu'est diffusée
sur 10 radio canada télé et sur facebook
reste à vie il sera trop tard
si les états signataires de l'accord de
paris se limite à leurs engagements
actuels
la température de la planète pour
augmenter de 3 degrés d'ici la fin du
siècle
l'impact sur l'humanité serait
catastrophique depuis un siècle la
température de la planète augmenté de
presque 1 degré celsius ce qui provoque
déjà un dérèglement climatique ce qui
entraîne une augmentation des événements
météorologiques extrêmes une forte crue
des glaces une hausse du niveau des
océans une diminution de la biodiversité
dans ce contexte on comprend qu'avec un
réchauffement de 1,5 à 2 degrés la
situation ne pourrait que fortement
s'aggraver
par exemple le risque d'inondation
serait doublé avec une augmentation de
1,5 degré et tripler avec une
augmentation de 2 degrés avec une hausse
de deux degrés les chaleurs extrêmes
toucherait près de deux fois et demie
plus de personnes qu'avec 1,5 degré au
delà de deux degrés les impacts serait
catastrophique et irréversible la
machine climatique pourrait s'emballer
bref il n'y aurait plus de frein pour
stopper la dérive du leem
mais le plus gros émetteur de gaz à
effet de serre dans le monde c'est la
chesnaie son milliard 300 millions
d'habitants
mais la pollution étant devenue un sujet
de préoccupation aussi de mobilisation
majeure de la population parce que la
pollution de l'air cause un million de
morts prématurées chaque année le
gouvernement a dû en tenir compte et
depuis plusieurs années la chine
investit massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables
[Musique]
annick alors est ce qu'on peut dire que
la chine a vraiment pris un virage vert
oui en ce sens où elle est devenu en
quelques années le leader dans la
production d'énergie solaire et dans la
fabrication de panneaux on peut voir des
normes ferme où il ya des panneaux à
perte de vue sur des kilomètres et des
kilomètres et dans ce pays où si souvent
plus gros plus grand et bien la chine a
inauguré le mois dernier la plus grande
centrale solaire en asie ça dans le
désert de gobi
la chine qui tous est un leader en
énergie éolienne et qui domine également
la production de véhicules électriques
est le mois de la quelques mois le
gouvernement central s'est lancé dans
une restructuration pour pouvoir
regrouper une quinzaine d'administration
en deux ministères qui sont dédiés à la
location des ressources la protection de
l'environnement à la lutte contre la
pollution et ça fait déjà deux ou trois
ans que les autorités centrales sont
lancés dans des inspections à l'échelle
du pays pour vérifier entre autres la
qualité de l'eau parce qu'à l'époque un
problème de pollution de l'air ici et
elles ont serré la vis en quelque sorte
à des milliers et des milliers
d'entreprises dans l'industrie lourde
matters particulier dans des provinces
minières et à la clé il ya eu des
centaines de millions de dollars
d'amendé des sanctions il ya eu aussi
des renvois de d'officiels de
responsables par milliers donc des
investissements massifs et des
subventions pour cette transition
énergétique en 2017
on parlait de plus de 150 milliards de
dollars et les militants verts ici
souligne que la consommation charbon
s'est stabilisée au pays depuis quelques
années même avec une réduction
considérable en certains endroits par
exemple à pékin pour se tourner
entre autres vers le gaz naturel mais
l'économie reste le moteur principal de
la chine alors si elle tourne au ralenti
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on diminue là
aussi les objectifs de réduction de gaz
à effet de serre oui ça arrive c'est le
cas dans la région de pékin où les
industries lourdes non pas à réduire
autant leurs émissions de particules
fines que l'an dernier pour le conduire
à la productivité à la production donc
parfois ces deux pas en avant un pas en
arrière il ya des ratés encore des défis
entre autres la chine entre autres
exemples la chine doit vraiment
améliorer la distribution à l'échelle du
pays de son énergie éolienne qui produit
dans des régions désertiques et peu
peuplée est donc la chine qui est un peu
à la croisée des chemins ne peut pas
reculer et elle ne peut elle sait ne
plus passer parce que la population de
plus en plus exigeante elle suit par
exemple en temps réel avec des
applications et la qualité de l'air dans
les villes c'est pas fait partie des
rares manifestations toléré dans ce pays
où le pays le gouvernement affiche une
volonté politique il a déjà dit qu'il
voulait transformer la chine en
civilisation écologique et comme le
souligne greenpeace chine est bien la
chine a fait vraiment un grand bout de
chemin
là elle est passée de zéro énergie
renouvelable à la position de leader et
ce en une décennie
mais quand même tout un défi gigantesque
là pour la chine cette révolution verte
merci beaucoup anik jean prix etienne
vous vous les suivez les chinois montent
dans les conférences climatique donc ils
ont vraiment amorcer ce virage vert ou
est tout à fait charger discours
complètement complètement il on y
profite un peu je dirais du vide de
l'essai par les américains qui ne sont
plus vraiment des leaders en la matière
et donc hippie profitent de ce vide mais
ils nous ont montré que un fond le
modèle qu'ils ont développés sont allés
jusqu'au bout et que la question des
changements climatiques en chine c'est
d'abord et avant tout une question de
santé publique nous et de qualité de
l'air de qualité de l'eau comme le dit
plus respirer un etc et c'est pour ça
qu'on est obligé d'agir parce que les
chinois a commencé à descendre dans la
rue dans certaines villes on n'a pas
beaucoup entendu parler de ça mais le
gouvernement chinois a eu peur que ça
devienne une révolution politique parce
que c'était polluer donc les chinois
nous ont montré que aller jusqu'au bout
du modèle où on peut polluer sans
vergogne sans payer ça donne ça
aujourd'hui donc ils ont évidemment
beaucoup de capitaux ils sont devenus
les leaders dans la production de
panneaux solaires dans le développement
des énergies renouvelables pas un pays
au monde où on n'investit plus en chine
dans les énergies renouvelables
évidemment parallèlement il continue à
construire des centrales au charbon mais
il me montre quand même que avec de la
volonté politique et c'est toujours ça
elles font qu'on a envie de turin c'est
possible de changer les choses ils sont
entrés de paver la voie peut-être à ce
que les autres pays industrialisés
pourront faire parce que les chinois
nous disent aujourd'hui on fait plus
partie des pays en voie de développement
ont fait partie des pays industrialisés
et à nous de faire notre part dans le
problème que nous avons mais les hommes
vous disiez profitent du retrait des
états unis s'engouffrer la non mais il
faut quand même le dire à une précision
parce que c'est vrai que c'est le plus
grand pollueur en termes global mais par
cas père capitale n'est pas en fait les
chinois pour du moins comme un peu
d'affolement ce canadienne par rapport à
la chine est très mauvaise par habitant
on doit avoir des taux d'émission de
près de quatre fois supérieure
un habitant chinois donc fait leur faire
la leçon puisque on aimait plus que par
habitant avec tous les émissions
historiques bien sûr mais plus longtemps
sont exactement mais de façon encore
plus inquiétant dont le bienvenu dans le
reportage
la chine elle seule au cours des quatre
dernières années à 2015 2016 2017 et
même 2018 selon bloomberg a investi à
elle seule plus que les états unis et
l'ensemble de l'europe réunis en matière
d'énergies renouvelables
ils se sont dit ça sera moi le leader
mondial de cette nouvelle énergie du 21e
siècle se pose la question ici
maintenant l'échelle canadienne
québécoise on fait quoi dans un pays qui
se prétend être un leader énergétique
avec des ressources extraordinaires dans
l'ouest pétrole et gaz au québec hydro
christ et manitoba ici donc beaucoup de
ressources énergétiques mais on tarde à
prendre ce virage pour pouvoir se dire
nous devons nous aussi massivement
investir dans ce secteur pour que dans
quelques générations on ne se fasse pas
dire par nos enfants vous étiez ou
lorsque nous étions un leader dans ce
secteur maintenant on doit importer
complètement l'ensemble ces technologies
c'est encore temps de jouer un rôle
important et le des façons d'y arriver
parce que vous devez toujours comme on y
fait cette proposition par ces
stratégies de finance responsable c'est
un peu le virage commence à faire la
caisse de dépôt au fondaction depuis
longtemps la ftq a mené s'effondre
traite à mener cette finance responsable
de plus en plus présente sur des
stratégies efficaces en matière de
décarbonisation principalement dans le
secteur énergétique
et ça aussi on appelle ça crée à la fois
de la richesse et faire des gains en
matière de changements climatiques
ça reste là aussi fondamentale et ça
presse oui mais ça c'est un film est
quand même ou individuellement est ce
qu'on n'a pas aussi une responsabilité
sur ce qu'on achète un bel avantage la
chine en fait c'est que c'est une
économie très centralisé mais
effectivement on achète beaucoup de
choses la chine
et si on veut vraiment défendre de notre
empreinte écologique notre empreinte
carbone on eu tout intérêt à favoriser
des circuits économiques plus court donc
acheter des produits locaux et à faire
une économie circulaire l'eucharistie
ce que je trouve que il
la chaîne des mondes malgré tout c'est
que l'économie d'une construction
sociale donc à partir du moment où on
choisit qu'une volonté politique pour
transformer les mécanismes qui contribue
à l'exploitation des écosystèmes et à la
dégradation et bien on peut agir donc
déjà de réaliser ça c'est un pas et
ensuite de prendre les mesures les choix
individuels et collectifs que ce soit
par nous nous notre pouvoir d'achat j'ai
souvent dit acheter c'est voter et sa
défaveur
mais voter c'est aussi un pouvoir qui
est fondamental on va aller aux
élections on va avoir des élections
bientôt au fédéral et une fois que les
élections ont lieu comme au québec
maintenant il faut continuer à mettre la
pression exigeaient des lois qu'ils
fassent en sorte que notre économie soit
véritablement responsable il pendant que
la chine avance quand même dans cette
voie là y'a quand même de plus en plus
de lieder climato sceptiques on le
conseille donald chantreau fait penser à
un sonar au brésil et à plusieurs
leaders en europe alors comment est ce
qu'on peut y arriver donc à 7 à 16
degrés est intéressant les américains
ont de moins en moins de gros chapitres
à cause de donald sommes justement et on
se rend compte que dans le grand ballet
des diplomatique
il ne compte plus beaucoup et on se dit
de toute façon aux états unis qui quand
même le 2 ans + g deuxième plus grand
pollueur au monde
il ya plein de monde qui font beaucoup
de choses les villes les états il ya
beaucoup de décideurs qui ont beaucoup
d'emprise sur ce qu'ils peuvent faire
donc que donald trump soho pouvoir dans
le fond ça change pas grand chose un
terrain ça sur le terrain et sur le
bilan total des médias telle urgence
d'agir
oui vous allez me parler de l'arctique
alors voilà donc l'arctique est
l'épicentre si vous voulez si c'est là
que ça se réchauffe le plus rapidement
et c'est là qu'on compte on peut voir
dans le fond à vitesse grand v se
dérouler les changements climatiques
dont je les prépare une petite capsule
nature ou bien de ça
l'article l épicentre dit réchauffement
climatique
selon les scientifiques les températures
grimpent deux fois plus vite dans cette
région qu'ailleurs sur la planète car le
miroir blanc de la banquise renvoient
les rayons du soleil mais avec la
fondent la surface de mer pouvait de
glace diminue et l'océan sombre qui la
remplace absorbent ces radiations ce qui
accélère le réchauffement et fait
craindre normalement un record de
foreman est établi en mars 2017
il y à d'autres conséquences au dg le
méthane et le co2 des gaz à effet de
serre emprisonné dans le pergélisol
pourrait aussi être libérés tout comme
des bactéries et des virus
le réchauffement de l'arctique a fait
aussi grandement la faune et la flore de
la région très au delà de la perte
d'habitat que cela signifie pour l'ours
polaire ses semblables
le dégel de l'arctique pourrait
perturber les courants océaniques le
même la fonte de la calotte du groenland
risque de faire augmenter le niveau des
océans
le gie elle prévoit qu'avec un
réchauffement de deux degrés celsius
le niveau des mers pourrait augmenter de
80 centimètres d'ici la fin du siècle
met en danger la vie de 10 millions de
personnes supplémentaires
c'est un scénario catastrophique dont on
vit déjà certaines conséquences
notamment dans les zones côtières on l'a
vu récemment aux îles de la madeleine
c'est le cas aussi à cap bateau au
nouveau brunswick où chaque année la mer
avale un peu plus la terre
mauvais daniel du gué résidents de
quatre bateaux propriétaire de ma maison
ici depuis 1991
je me suis ici parce que je suis né à
quatre bateaux juste fait mon petit coin
de paradis
j'ai toujours vécu site
avec les marées qui de plus en plus
hautes avec la fonte des glaciers
ça crie beaucoup des vosgiens le premier
titre en menacer les routes sont menacés
et tempête soit plus en plus fréquemment
de plus en plus fort des ventes
ont-ils 100 km en voyez pas souvent
c'est qu'on peut arriver une fois toutes
les trois heures mais là ça peut arriver
souvent deux ou trois fois dans la même
semaine
en décembre 2016 j'ai perdu 17 pieds de
terrain juste d'un coup depuis 1991 j'ai
perdu 75 pieds de tyra environ
extrêmement stressé rdsa puis dessus
puis nos terrains nos maisons carte de
la valeur nos puis nous pureté jeunes
ont trop potable des menaces et mon club
tézier seulement
qui du bord du car classés de la
protection à nos frais moi j'ai pas les
moyens de le faire à la vitesse que
l'érosion ce fait
succès paraît et et je pense que cette
question de questions de 5 à 6 ans
peut-être
envoi par ordre de maison ici
quand je regarde des séries sur un titre
que je me sois en bien
ça fait partie de moi je n'imagine pas
vivre ailleurs
[Musique]
l'érosion c'est vraiment un problème
réel on le voit mais pour nous ce sont
les inondations qui sont la plus grande
menace les changements climatiques sur
une fesse de toutes sortes de façons au
canada l'érosion c'est une chose les
feux de forêt on le voit mais au canada
la plus grande menace selon les experts
dans l'est dans les 20 à 30 prochaines
années
ce sont les inondations et on le vus
dans les dernières années calgary
toronto la grande région de montréal ont
toutes été inondées et à chaque fois que
des inondations les plans de d'urgence
se raffine un peu plus mais en général
les experts s'entendent au canada pour
dire qu'on est assez mal préparés pour
faire face aux inondations dans le
trajet contrairement à d'autres pays par
exemple aux pays bas où j'étais l'année
dernière qui ont évidemment depuis des
décennies mis en place des plans qui
sont plus efficaces et qui redonne en
fait au cours d'eau un peu de place donc
il redonne la classe qu'avait le cours
d'eau avant que l'humain change tout le
paysage
donc on en est là il faut s'adapter donc
à celle conséquences des changements
climatiques on n'a plus le choix qu'est
ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on fait lorsqu'il
ya deux il ya vraiment de deux grandes
voix c'est à dire que d'un côté je pense
qu'il va falloir accepter que des choses
qu'on a fait qu'on ne pourra plus faire
valoir quitter les berges à cet endroit
parce que il ya quand même un niveau qui
est atteint ou on pourra pas simplement
essayé de se protéger des endroits où
faut faire abandonner
d'un autre côté évidemment c'est
difficile pour les difficiles mais il y
des choix qui ont été qui à petite
échelle n'ont pas d'impact mais quand
c'est généralisé il y en a trop mal
évidemment la mise à l'échelle passe pas
l'épreuve du test il ya des conséquences
qui ne trompent plus nécessairement
inversible falloir accepter ce bon c'est
très déprimant
il ya ce volet qu'il faut me accepté
constat d'un autre côté ils demandent le
génie québécois des le fait plusieurs
preuves
il faut travailler au développement des
technologies et des solutions aux
protégés les endroits où il ya encore
espoir de protéger ces endroits là
vraiment on a eu les anciennes
techniques qui fonctionnent plus ou
moins bien là rochman choses comme ça
mais là ils développent des nouvelles
techniques pour eux c'est pas coupé les
vannes il faut il faut devenir plus
agile dans l'expérimentation de ces
nouvelles stratégies pour protéger les
endroits où on pense hélas les
gouvernements c'est quand même une
question qui est compliqué parce qu'il
ya des droits acquis à des actions là
depuis des années est ce que ce sont les
responsables de ce qui leur arrive
bon c'est pas très clair tout le monde
est un peu responsable de ce qui arrive
un peu partout mais je pense pas que le
citoyen seul peut faire quelque chose
il doit y avoir des stratégies et des
plans d'urgence mis en place des plans
de mitigation mais il faut les réduire
ça peut être une zone totalement ça peut
être une opportunité on peut transformer
le problème en opportunité c'est à dire
au lieu de justement de 2 d'aménager des
bâtiments détours au bord de l'eau on
peut en faire un parc
une fois que ce gars est une fondation
le parc sera inondée puis trois semaines
plus tard il y aura pas de problème
personnes arrêtées par sedan n'aura subi
les conséquences
mais évidemment il faut sur les
promoteurs qui sont très intéressés le
système fiscal au québec où les villes
en fait la seule ressource qu'ils ont
comme revenu c'est le
la taxe foncière ils sont toujours
incité à construire davantage ça c'est
un grand problème au québec mais la
gestion des inondations
alors si on laisse du terrain au cours
d'eau pour pour prendre leur place pour
respirer
naturellement eh bien on aura moins de
problèmes et on pourra créer des espaces
verts qui vont améliorer la qualité de
vie de tous les citoyens végétalisée
c'est un geste qui peut être fait aussi
de manière très concrète sur les sur les
berges pour prévenir l'érosion ville est
la valeur de ces biens services
écologiques leur redonner leur rôle
qu'ils ont à jouer ça signifie qu'en
matière d'adaptation parce que depuis le
but on a parlé de réduction des
émissions donc l'adaptation au
changement climatique
il faut que le gouvernement intervienne
pour bien sûr financer ces mesures qui
seront très très coûteuse et en même
temps les municipalités ont un rôle
fondamental à jouer et comment on a
parlé de l'océan puisque c'est rare
qu'on en parle en king sa langue
non seulement le niveau de la mer
augmente mais en plus l'océan
s'acidifient à cause des changements
climatiques donc ça signifie que la
capacité des océans de produire des
ressources de la pêche diminue vont
mieux de plus en plus et ça ne voit qu
accentuer les contraintes alimentaires
d'où l'urgence encore une fois
d'intervenir dans ce domaine mais parce
que l'avenir est entre leurs mains un
peu d'espoir ici nous avons rencontré
les enfants de l'école primaire les amis
du monde à montréal il nous donne à nous
les adultes quelques conseils vous en
hiver
est-ce qu'ils avaient une fois attention
à l'environnement
non parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
maturité pour pour faire attention à sec
à leur geste ils devraient utiliser lé
transport en commun comme il fait plus
chaud et du réchauffement climatique
alors les glaciers vont fondre puis ça
va on va ailleurs il y aurait plus de
qui ça va envahir les villes près de la
mer la terre va se réchauffer puis à
colle tout ça ça va être trop chaud puis
au pourrait peut-être pas ses envies
si on veut pas de pollution il faut
mieux les utiliser composter recyclé
parce que sinon ça va être tentée hearts
et les animaux les autres peuvent
s'étouffer et moi j'ai mes animaux je
veux pas comment on peut faire beaucoup
de choses mais moi je crois aussi un peu
utilisé une bouteille réutilisable moins
consommer quand je suis plus dans une
chambre où il peut besoins de l'animal
j'ai fait ma lumière pour ne pas
gaspiller électricité et qu'il sur le
vélo le post une voiture respectueuse et
la même voiture avec d autres personnes
étaient amis
tu lisais plus d'éoliennes et amont et
des panneaux solaires pour générer de
l'électricité pour les tâches et les
petits contenants de yoko on peut
prendre un gros contenants de yoko au
lieu de jeter au compost et aux risques
l'âge on peut réutiliser
si je fais des gestes qui détruisent la
terre
mais quand mes enfants vont grandir van
vo interdit des terres pour faire tel
tous déjà utilisé et ils ont ça va être
plus dur pour eux de vives que nous vous
les grandes personnes avouent devrait
aider la planète parce que la planète
c'est neutre notre maison oui la planète
c'est notre maison comme elle vient de
le dire justement c'est l'avenir ce sont
les enfants et en une question justement
là-dessus de dominique vézina pour laure
waridel la question est la suivante
qu'est ce que l'école peut faire pour
jouer pleinement son rôle il soutenir
tous ces jeunes quand ils entendent dans
leur désir d'action l'école a énormément
à farrelly professeurs qui sont aussi
peuvent intégrer des notions
environnementales dans pratiquement tous
les cours et ceux du primaire même à
partir des cpe jusqu'à l'université et
ça se fait pas suffisamment fait on
oublie que y'a pas d'économie sans et
costa mieux pas de politique sans
écosystèmes et pas de société sans et
costa myopathies science en écho aux
sables on doit protéger le mintier de la
vie sur terre on est rendu là en fait et
pour ceux les éducateurs par tous les
professeurs ont un rôle super important
joué que j'aurai toute la communauté
éducative et au québec on a vraiment des
programmes fabuleux en éducation
relative à l'environnement on a des gens
qui s'impliquent dans toutes sortes
d'organisations une conservation de la
nature et et et autres donc fini par se
lier
r oui déjà l'école commencé à aller à
l'école à pied en vélo donc encourager
les jeunes arrivés avec des boîtes à
lunch et zéro déchet par exemple les
amener à composter beaucoup de choses
intéressantes qui sont pu les aider à
comprendre le fait qu' on ait l'air
qu'on respire look on boit la nourriture
qu'on mange on est l'environnement donc
ce qu'on fait l'environnement se le
faire nous mêmes à partir du moment où
on aura tous intégrés saab a fait à
partir de l'école primaire je pense que
nous avons une différence est oui
rapidement devants 10 secondes on quitte
le québec à l'échelle internationale
dans la dernière conférence la coop des
parties ce qu'on se dit c'est il faut
éduquer notamment les femmes et les
filles parce qu'elles ont un rôle
fondamental à jouer dans les questions
de population et dans les questions de
changement climatique fois qu un lien
évident au niveau international entre
ces questions d'alimentation le
changement climatique et d'éducation en
particulier important avoir accès
lorsqu'on est une femme partout sur la
planète on appelle ça les objectifs de
développement durable des nations unies
vaste programme maintenant vu que c'est
la dernière pause publicitaire je
voudrais vous présenter quelqu'un qui va
nous accompagner après l'émission parce
qu'après cette émission sur la télé ça
continue aussi sur facebook live il
s'agit de dominique paquin qui fait
partie du collectif
ouranos on s'inquiète bidamant de tout
ce qui se passe avec les changements
climatiques ce que vous avez vu ce soir
ici les questions du public aussi qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire est ce que vous
pensez qu'on est rendu une autre prise
de conscience ou c'est un petit pas en
avant a de plus c'est comme ça qu'on
avance dans le fond oui je pense
qu'effectivement la prise conscience
elle est vraiment importante et elle est
réelle il ya dix ans et demi à cinq ans
on n'aurait pas pu avoir une émission
comme ce sera réglé
exemple inspire même si en même temps
avec un constat d'urgence et un
sentiment de responsabilité notamment
quand on pense aux jeunes
les reportages sur les jeunes aux états
unis qui ont des poursuites judiciaires
avec des exemples dans les écoles
responsabilité une urgence d'agir
consommer il ya un espoir dans la prise
de conscience
vraiment alors donc on va se retrouver
dans à peu près une quinzaine de minutes
justement pour faire le point sur tout
ce qui nous a été présenté et d'autres
questions aussi parce que vous continuez
évidemment de nous envoyer ces questions
sur facebook live je peux déjà vous dire
aussi que non seulement on a quinze
minutes de plus ce soir mais que demain
à midi toujours sur facebook live on
aura l'occasion de débattre davantage de
parler avec étienne leblanc qui va faire
le point aussi sur d'autres questions et
d'autres initiatives populaires parce qu
apparemment ça vous intéresse beaucoup à
partir de chez vous de votre maison
justement de faire votre petit plus pour
l'environnement dont vous restez avec
nous l'émission est dans son dernier
droit ici sur ici radio canada télé et
que je vous disais donc on vous retrouve
de l'autre côté du générique justement
pour vous présenter d'autres réponses en
compagnie de dominic paquet d'ouranos
merci beaucoup
l'émission se poursuit dans un astre
[Musique]
alors chose promise chose due j'en avais
parlé en début d'émission sébastien les
téléspectateurs et les internautes ont
été assez nombreux quand même à réagir à
tout ça on leur avait posé une question
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts à faire ou
à ne pas faire pour la planète
alors ouais vraiment pluie de
commentaires ce soir c'est ce que l'on
constate vraiment la proposition que
l'on vous a fait et semble avoir plu et
dans les commentaires on retrouve
plusieurs des grands thèmes que l'on a
abordé au cours de l'émission alors à la
question qui êtes vous prêt à faire pour
l'environnement anaïs de québec répond
réduire réutiliser recycler c'est la
base quoique réutiliser on l'a vu ça
demeure un défi et lundi
j'achète de plus en plus en vrac ma
nourriture on peut seulement recyclées
mais réduire à la source c'est une façon
de le faire est presque vegan en plus
voilà lysanne dit bon je fais des boîtes
à lunch zéro déchet est probablement
pour ses enfants sans produit beaucoup
dans une année elle aborde également
dangereux du transport elle vient de
joliette et dit paul choix on prend
l'autocar le transport en commun n'est
pas assez développé
ça demeure un enjeu ensuite marjolaine
plus aucun produit d'origine animale
dans mon assiette depuis quelques années
vous l'avez souligné s'étend un
commentaire qui revient assez souvent et
elle met plusieurs solutions en
application vous le voyez julie
courchesne je m'abstiens de prendre
l'avion je n'ai pas d'enfant et je n'en
aurai pas ça les enfants les enfants et
les avions ce sont des commentaires qui
reviennent quelquefois ça semble un peu
extrême est ce que c'est ce que ça prend
certaines sont pas prêts en tout cas
aller jusque le voyez ce qu'écrit chloé
de montréal et dit je dois prendre
l'avion pour aller visiter ma famille
alors je ne vois pas y renoncer pour
l'instant car je n'ai pas d'autres
options pour y allier et en terminant 1
courriel que j'ai trouvé bien
sympathique jacinthe il ya un an et demi
j'ai vendu ma voiture pour prendre
l'autobus et j'ai fait un virage zéro
déchet j'ai longtemps hésité parce que
je croyais que ma vie serait plus
difficile mais ce n'est pas le cas je
suis encore un peu intense pour mon
entourage mais plusieurs se mettre dans
la mesure de leurs moyens
voilà alors des gens vraiment qu'ils
agissent motivé merci beaucoup c'est 26
rue alors en terminant vous trois
concrètement si vous aviez une chose à
prioriser du point de vue collectif pour
atteindre justement cette transition
juste dont on parle
qu'est ce que ce serait le concert
initialement développée plus
d'alternative donc mettre des voies
réservées mètres des voies réservées au
transport en commun à la marche ou vélo
vraiment développer plus d'alternative
pour que les gens puissent choisir de se
déplacer autrement c'est une
définitivement ce qu'il faut faire
rapidement fédéral ça et c'est cette
gratuité de polluer éliminer cette
iniquité fiscale en matière de pollution
et donc imposer un prix carbone sur
l'ensemble du territoire canadien
à l'échelle du québec pouvoir définir
une stratégie qui est hyper ambitieuse
et qui va réunir collectivement cette
société pour qu'on soit un modèle
exemplaire les consonnes société plus
prospère plus j'espère que monsieur
legault soit les cotations alors réalisé
que chacun nous avons beaucoup plus de
pouvoir qu on serait porté à croire
surtout quand on se met ensemble canton
crédit mouvement allait signer le pacte
pour la transition suivre certaines des
nez des suggestions qui sont à n'en ai
aussi proposé ensemble des mesures
déréglementation des lois qui s'assure
que les décisions qu'on prend passe le
crible des réductions des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre pour s'attaquer
sérieusement aux changements climatiques
collectif mais pour les pour les
citoyens individuellement qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire une chose alors bat
tous les jours on mange notre compte un
impact à ce niveau là trois fois par
jour on peut choisir de fait tous notre
consommation de viande de choisir des
produits les moins emballés possible le
plus local possible plus biologiques
possibles de manière plus générale
réduire notre consommation et ça c'est
très économiques souvent ont dû faire
des choix écologiques
ça coûte cher mais raison notre
consommation c'est le premier geste à
poser et ça coûte pas cher
kocher lundi être cohérent dans nos
achats dans nos biens de consommation et
dans certains cas accepter de payer plus
cher pour pouvoir faire des gains
matière d'environnement ça peut être ça
aussi on aperçoit la cohérence entre nos
principes et nos actions fondamentales
je veux dire s'engager à prendre le
transport en commun la marche ou le vélo
ouvre une fois par mois une fois par
semaine donc y aller progressivement
mais inclure ces mots delà dans nos
choix et traduire le télétravail quand
c'est possible
une fois pas moins une fois par semaine
dont vraiment y aller progressivement
expérimentées c'est beau de l'eau et en
faire de nouveaux choix qu'on a notre
mobilité tout et ça semble assez assez
faisable en fait
etienne le mot de la fin ben moi je
pense que ce qu'on a vu le pendant toute
l'émission c'est que cette transition
énergétique
elle est complexe et les difficiles
autant pour les citoyens pour les
décideurs politiques et parfois on peut
avoir l'impression que la transition
énergétique elle sera plus facile pour
les personnes qui ont plus d'argent pour
les mieux nantis et je pense qu'il est
très important pour les décideurs
politiques quand ils mettent des mesures
en place de tenir compte du fait que si
ça coûte plus cher si on taxe les
produits coûtent plus cher de tenir
compte des gens qui ont moins d'argent
de tenir compte des gens qui vont
peut-être perdre leur emploi à cause de
cette transition énergétique de leur
donner des moyens de se former d'aller
travailler à gagner de les accompagner
dans ce parce que c'est pas vrai que on
peut imposer aux gens sans les
accompagner sont les aider à les inciter
à faire cette transition c'est pas
d'accompagnement genre ça c'est le grand
défilé va donner comme révolte sociale
voilà les solutions sont complexes mais
on dirait qu'elles sont encore plus
complexes qu'on se rend compte que ces
mesures peuvent avoir des effets sur les
citoyens ordinaires les travailleurs etc
et je crois que le gouvernement est
obligé aujourd'hui de médecins dans son
eau dans la grande soupe pour trouver
une solution efficace qu'on a vu ce soir
qui a quand même des solutions qui
existent
il ya des choses qu'on peut faire puis
c'était le but de l'exercice alors voilà
pour cette émission spéciale
j'espère que ça vous a plu que cela vous
a inspiré peut-être même faire rêver en
tout cas il y avait matière à réflexion
c'était vraiment cette l'objectif de
cette émission est d'ailleurs fait
retrouver tous les reportages qu'on vous
a présenté ce soir dans le dossier
climat sur le site de radio canada
pourrait également voir l'entrevue
intégrale que je réalise
avec nicolas hulot l'intégrale sera
diffusée la semaine prochaine sur ici a
dit et sur notre site merci à tous
d'avoir été là merci à nos trois invités
vraiment ça a été une soirée formidable
très instructive merci le fim
merci beaucoup et tiennent d'abord merci
à vous le public d'avoir assisté à cette
émission
merci aussi au musée de l'environnement
nous avoir si bien accueilli ce soir
bonsoir
à la prochaine
[Musique]
alors voilà donc c'est la partie on va
dire télévisuelle qui vient de se
terminer mais cette émission se poursuit
sur facebook live comme on vous l'avait
promis jeu